e
okay folks two minute warning two
right folks it is 1000 hours here in
state federal veterans uh as is our
custom we will start with a pledge of
allegiance and I'm going to look at
representative Bennett perhaps and ask
might I pled to the flag of the United
States of America and to the Republic
for which it stands one nation God
okay at this time I'm going to hand my
gavl to our vice chair representative
Rollins because I am the prime sponsor
of this uh HCR
hcr1 house concurrent resolution 10
calling for the repeal of the Jones act
so uh represent Rollins uh good luck
chair recognizes representative MAF
sponsor thank you Mr Vice chair okay uh
I'm going to repre some arguments put
forth several years ago by Brian Riley
of the KO inst KO Institute uh on the
Jones act and you should have a handout
that's going around also from the KO
Institute on this measure
so the Jones Act is shorthand for the
Merchant Marine Act of
1920 and it provides a lesson in my view
on how economic
controls can backfire so the Jones Act
is described by the US Department of
Homeland Security as a protectionist
policy intended to protect and develop
the American Merchant Marine and US ship
building protectionist elements of the
Jones Act of 1920 include requirements
that ships transporting goods within the
United States must be us crude us owned
and US
built so these Provisions many of us
feel today over a century later are not
only unnecessary but
counterproductive so Jones act Defenders
and supporters um allege or claim that
requiring the use of us Crews for
domestic waterborne shipping protects
Americans against foreign terrorists and
spies freely traversing say the
Mississippi River disguised as ship
operators uh some of us feel that's
largely a scare tactic so with or
without the Jones act it's still illegal
for someone to work in the United States
without a permanent resident card
supposedly a work permit or an
employment related
visa and this is true whether they
transporting merchandise between us
ports or employed in any other job the
Jones act's requirements that ships
transporting goods between domestic
ports must be us owned deprives the
industry the maritime industry of
beneficial foreign
investment areas of the economy that are
open to foreign investment account for 7
million plus us jobs as other analysts
have pointed out removing ownership
limits would provide more opportunities
for Americans involved in domestic
waterborne transportation to also
benefit from job creating foreign
investment so as with foreign investment
in other us Industries ownership of
vessels providing waterborne
Transportation would be screened by the
committee on foreign investment in the
United States it's called the
cfius to to mitigate National Security
concerns or risks and also it's been
argued that modern ownership
Arrangements render the Jones act
ownership requirement
Obsolete and maybe the most criticized
element of the Jones act has been its
ban on the use of foreign built ships
for domestic shipping this is a unique
regulatory barrier no other similar
restrictions apply to domestic
transportation of merchandise by air
rail
truck as a result Americans pay infl
inflated prices for
ships according to a 2017 Congressional
research service report Coastal siiz
container ships built in the US cost six
to eight times more than comparable
foreign built
ships so the argument made by proponents
of maintaining the Jones Act is simple
the US needs a strong ship building
industry in the way to realize this goal
is by freeing it of the obligation to
compete with foreign ship
Builders but high tech tariffs don't
necessarily make Industries stronger
they actually can make them
weaker by reducing competition the Jones
act reduces the incentive for the US
ship Builders to innovate it's a problem
with
protectionism for take foreign car
competition I I drive a Nissan
Versa uh foreign car competition has
prompted American car manufacturers to
improve that people could buy Toyota
Toyotas instead of Fords makes Ford a
better company I remember in the 70s
Chrysler and American automobiles were
not very good buying large and they've
gotten much better why did they get
better because people started buying
Japanese cars so the American car
manufacturers improved their
product so according to the US Maritime
Administration the US non-defense Oceano
vessel Fleet declined from 193 ships in
2000 to
96 in October of 2018 it's probably less
than that
now and our na we don't build ships like
we used to not even close our Navy and
again this is state federal veterans
committee our Navy is down to around 280
ships give or take China by comparison
has around 500 ships so our great
decline in domestic ship building
creates National Security issues as well
as economic
issues so some of the strongest
Transportation manufacturing Industries
in the US operate in a low tariff
environment us production of aircraft
railroad Rolling Stock automobiles as I
said uh heavyduty trucks has been
increasing even though the government
does not force Americans to use us built
Planes Trains or automobiles when
transporting cargo as it does with ships
moreover the effective tariff rate for
imported recreational boats you know if
you have a if I spend time at wiip
places packed with recreational
boats so
the effective rate for these imported
recreational boats is just 1% but 95% of
the recreational boats sold domestically
are made in the USA without this this
protection so clearly American
manufacturer don't need High tariffs to
be successful they just need good
products in fact this their success is
contingent upon low trade barriers that
Foster Innovation and competition
quality products here's a specific
example of how the Jones act hurts
America uh a Washington State fishing
company uh it's called fisherman
Fisher's finest uh they commissioned a
new ship from Dakota Creek Industries
however because 7% 7 % of the ship's
steel was from Holland the ship was not
allowed to fish in US Coastal Waters so
here's an American built vessel and
because 7% of its its uh steel was from
another country it couldn't fish in US
Coastal Waters so George Will some of
you have heard of George will I'm a fan
of fiz I'll admit it so he wrote quote
fomenting spurious National Security
anxieties is the first Refuge of rent
seeking Scoundrels who tired up
protectionism as patriotism when they
inv vagle government into lining their
pockets with their fellow citizens money
unquote from George Will so trade
barriers undermine US security by
weakening the economy and creating
conflict with our allies here in New
England we need fuel oil natural gas
it's been a cold winter uh as you may
have noticed uh pipelines are great but
they largely tapped out and regulations
make it hard to build new ones and we'd
love to have a pipeline come through New
York but politicians in New York won't
let it happen so we depend on fuel
coming here via
ship recent wall Wall Street Journal
article stated that the Jones act
limitations add costs that encourage
fuel to be exported overseas City
group's Global head of commodity
research told the paper the Gulf Coast
is not selling diesel to Philadelphia or
New York they sell it to places like
Holland so you got fuel Laden ships from
America that to satisfy the Jones act
they they have to bring fuel here not
from the Gulf but from the from Holland
via the gulf it's uh absurd in my view
it's costly it's bad economics so again
the Jones Act is over 100 years old
and instead of receiving unending
protection from International
competition ship Builders should operate
in the same low tff policy under which
manufacturers as I said of trucks
automobiles planes and other Industries
are thriving so the Jones act should not
be allowed to inflict another 100 Years
or or 10 years or even even one year
this is a resolution that will be read
and heard if it moves forward and I hope
hope that when it does get this does get
to Executive
session uh this afternoon uh you'll
support this resolution that shines a
light on a serious situation while
encouraging Washington to take long
overdue action thank you Mr Vice chair
be happy to try to try to answer any
questions if there are any are there any
questions I'll start at the table and
come
around uh I just have a question why do
you think it hasn't has it been
addressed before and just not approved
or why do you think it hasn't been
addressed thank thank you for your
question representative Bennett uh it
has been addressed before I read uh
George Will's uh quote uh we addressed
it last term in this committee actually
uh I believe it came out of this
committee 1010 and it was table in the
floor so we tried to uh address it in
this very committee uh so we're trying
again and I I I think because it affects
New Hampshire especially it's good to
have this this discussion in the winter
time as I said because it's so cold and
and uh without pipelines and because we
depend on shipping to bring fuel here uh
it it matters to New Hampshire but yes
it's it's come up before and
uh not just here but uh all over the
country
actually further questions thank
you I know last time when we discussed
this there was a big um issue in regards
to the jobs that this would cost at the
Port um I don't have the exact figure on
Me on the number of jobs but there was
definitely a large amount of jobs that
this would affect thank you repres Cy
yes that came up last time around and
there's we get different numbers and
different perspectives on jobs in New
Hampshire if the Jones act uh were
repealed would that affect any or many
jobs so uh obviously
those of us who support the bill don't
think that that the any jobs lost if
there are any jobs lost would be
significant but that that's from a
resolution question thank you Mr Vice
chair so many Americans U may have
concerns with foreign ships conducting
cabotage in America's Coastal Waters and
inland waterways if the Jones Act is
fully repealed um with global turmoil
with major waterborne Commerce country
countries such as Russia and China do
you think it's prudent to completely
repeal the Jones act or do you think it
may be a better option to reform parts
of it thank you for the question
representative plant that that's a good
question I touched on that a little bit
in terms of uh crew ships and the
security concerns and I I did try to
address that earlier uh to your point if
Congress which we hope does take this up
they don't necessarily need to throw out
the whole uh repeal whole measure uh I
think you make a very interesting point
I think they could uh reform it was that
the term you used uh so that they have
the option of completely repealing it or
they could uh reform it to your point to
address in some fashion the consc the
security concerns if they're if they
consider those to be that real or viable
so that that's that's a good point they
don't necessarily have to repeal it they
could reform it if if they take it up in
questions representative ly thank you um
so I guess along those same lines
because that was actually the same
question I was going to ask uh is there
would you consider as a prime sponsor
amending the language to instead of say
repeal say amend and
address thank you for that uh as a prime
sponsor I certainly would be open to
discussing changing that language from
repeal to reform that's something I
think to Representatives representative
plants Point uh may not be unreasonable
uh so yes it's something that we could
at further
questions representative Bela thank you
Mr chairman thank you for presenting
this bill I have a brief two-part
question if it would be allowed but
first is given the um definition change
for clean energy that passed through
this House of Representatives
yesterday um would
this if it goes through and if Congress
acts and if they make the necessary
changes or repeal to the Jones act would
this not dramatically stand to increase
the availability of clean energy in New
Hampshire thank you for that first part
of your question the uh debate we had
yesterday in the house floor had to do a
lot with nuclear and and windmills and
whether they would be classified as as
clean
energy if we're talking natural gas that
seen that seem to be uh known to be a
cleaner not necessarily it's a fossil
fuel but it's cleaner than than coal or
or oil so yes I I agree I think that if
this moved forward and we could get
natural gas from the Gulf uh then that
would be uh a step in the right
direction for clean oil as you may know
the the bow power plant still uh
recently if not still has a coal
capability if we really need it so yes
uh I I think it could contribute to
clean energy in New
Hampshire follow up thank you and so the
second part of that would be given
the rather significant changes to the
energy environment that are currently
occurring in federal policy that New
England broadly has really put a lot of
its eggs in the offshore wind
basket uh uh which may now be cut off
effectively given some of the executive
orders that come down isn't it really
necessary to increase our access to
these energy sources to secure our grids
and home heating for winter yes I think
it's a measure this resolution and if we
can get the Jones act repealed or
modified uh to to your earlier point to
our earlier Point uh that would be
better for clean cleaner energy again in
terms of natural gas offshore wind I
know is in the news and uh it's
interesting how offshore wind is is
being tied into the Jones act but I
think your point about clean energy and
especially if if offshore wind does not
move forward the way it was projected to
then we will need to look at
Alternatives and and I think repealing
the Jones act would help us to get the
natural gas alternative that we I think
we
need further
questions repres
Buddha
um thank you m chair for taking my
question so were you the prime sponsor
of the same bill last term in the last
term thank you represent budha talki yes
I was I was the Prime sponsor last time
around follow
up would you sh lights
on
why the reasonings of opponents of this
bill last ter what what was the major
reasoning they give against or put forth
against this bill last time sure you've
heard one of them uh from the uh ranking
member there were concerns about
possible job losses and for the rest of
your question I know there are several
pink slips from some folks who do have
some uh knowledge and I think they could
articulate the the problems with the
Jones act much better than me as the
prime sponsor so if you'll if you can
wait a bit I'm sure you'll have some
folks that'll make the the alternative
case much better than I
could further
questions representative lloy thank you
um and thank you for taking my question
um the I guess my one of my other
concerns with this was would be in
regards to the US steel industry and
needing to use us steel Investments um
for this have we heard from any um any
Steel Workers unions or anything like
that thank for the question you seem to
recall a year ago or last term there was
someone from uh gilmington who
represented that segment of the labor
industry and they expressed concerns
that if we could have some amount of
foreign Steel in our ship building that
that could impact um
labor my thought after hearing that last
year was it it didn't seem to me to be a
a significant concern but that was just
opinion representative
Bennett thank you for taking my question
um I was wondering we're thinking about
jobs might be lost but would jobs be
gained in some ways because thank you
for that question I that's an excellent
question uh Bath Iron Works is a ship
builder in Maine and they build ships
and they we don't build as I touched on
earlier we don't build nearly as many
ships as we used to and with as the
point that I tried to make earlier and
that's a great question I think that we
think that removing some of the
protectionism would stimulate ship
building in America which we really
really need both uh mil naval military
and uh and also commercial so I think
that's a great point and I believe that
that if we get away from the Jones act
that it would be good for employment
Jones Thank you Mr chair and
representative thank you for coming to
our committee
happy to be here I I a couple of times
Ed the term artificially inflated
shipping is not a nice way of saying
coercion sure thank you for the for the
question and comment uh coercion I think
is is not a inaccurate term tariffs are
in the news a lot I know and so it's
interesting we're talking about tariffs
here and the whole tariff issue there's
many pieces to it generally
uh you know I am with the free trade out
free trade folks there are times where
tariffs uh are justifiable uh I I think
I I hate to contradict uh uh some folks
in DC I think short-term tariffs
sometimes have their place and there
there are reasons for them but
generally they raise prices they hurt uh
domestic jobs uh as I've already talked
about so uh yeah the
you could deem some of this coercive uh
but almost any legislative act could be
seen as is prompting some response or or
some activity that some would deem
coercive that coercive is kind of a
strong word um gentle prodding is a way
I would prefer to term
it I'll take a couple more question
representative thank you for taking my
question is there any fear that uh
repealing the Jones act would fully
decimate the US ship building industry
in that regard and make us more reliant
on uh foreign countries um like China
for instance you know we're using
Chinese ships to move Goods around the
US from coast to coast what if all of a
sudden one day uh the Chinese Communist
Party decided we're not we're not going
to allow you to use our ships anymore
then what do we do sure I touched thank
you for the question I touched on that
earlier and the the notion that
repealing the Jones act would uh hurt
our
domestic shipping
capabilities as I said earlier I think
it's the opposite I think that repealing
the Jones act would be better for ship
building and for American Commerce and I
cited the examples of planes and trains
and and Automobiles which are not
protected The Way domestic ship building
is and and they're thriving with
competition so that would be my response
uh to that concern I I think that it
would repealing Jones act would would be
security any further
questions seeing none thank you
representative MAF excellent job thank
Maguire thank you Mr chairman and
members of the committee for the record
my name is Dan Maguire I represent the
town of Epsom and I've been very happy
to co-sponsor this bill um the basic
issue here
is the Jones Act is is about um the
concept of free markets versus
protectionism and the Jones Act is
probably the best or one of the best
examples that we have that protectionism
doesn't work it was passed 105 years ago
at the time the US ship building
industry was the premier in the world
right and and the protectionism Pro of
provided by the Jones act caused that
industry to lack competition so that
we've gotten to the point where these
these uh large commercial ships simply
aren't built in the US anymore right
because they're not competitive they're
they you know the the industry has
dwindled to the point that that you
simply can't get um liquid natural gas
type of ships a lot of container ships
and so on without the kind of um
expensive cost that that the prime
sponsor just mentioned so then the
question is if it's so bad why do we
still have it right why do we have it
105 years later right and the problem is
a political one this is one of those
examples of concentrated benefits and
diverse costs right so so the people
that Ben there are obviously some people
who benefit right there the people who
have the protected industry get some
benefit from it they don't have to
compete it's easier for them Etc but and
so they know who they are and they can
go to and Lobby and and push to keep
their benefits but the the everybody who
pays higher shipping costs right the the
cost of your uh whatever that that gets
shipped to the United States or get
shipped from one part of the United
States to another is a little bit more
expensive but that's diverse right
that's that's you know pennies here and
pennies there so they don't know to go
and and um advocate for their position
because and it's not worth it to them to
advocate for their position and that's
why things like this um
continue I um sent you a few
examples uh I I sent you an email today
which which has plenty of uh articles
and and so on um about the situation
I'll give you um three specific examples
um just to kind of illustrate the
problems um the uh Puerto
Rico um need needs energy right they get
they use liquid natural gas for energy
and they currently are receiving it from
Chile right so it has to be shipped over
5,000 nautical miles through the Panama
Canal when right you know right in the
United States we have Pennsylvania has
plenty of natural gas plenty of shipping
we ship liquid natural gas to Europe and
other places and it's you know 1,500
miles away no Panama Canal much much
cheaper the problem is there doesn't
exist um us-made liquid natural gas
ships so anytime you ship it it has to
be shipped one end of the of the of the
transaction has to be a foreign country
right because in that case the Jones act
doesn't apply and you can use the ships
that exists right so so Puerto Rico pays
an exorbitant amount for their energy
simply because of the Jones act um and
next next one is um I handed out today
um this letter from the New England
Governors uh it a couple of years ago
with the price of um natural gas was
getting high we had a tough winter and
so on so all six governors of New
England wrote um wrote a
um a letter to secretary granholm asking
for her to suspend the Jones act so that
New England could get shipments of
natural gas from Pennsylvania and the
Gulf Coast right directly from the
United States the U like I said the
United States is an exporter and so
because there are no such ships when we
get liquid natural gas for winter it has
to come from Europe right so it's it's
just expensive and unnecessary and so on
I mean we ship to Europe and Europe
ships to us I mean it doesn't make any
sense and um so that s so so all of the
New England Governors not just
Republicans not just Democrats but
everybody um sent a letter and please
get you know let us be out of the Jones
act at least I mean they ask for
temporary but you know the the the
problem is is ongoing okay um and then
um let's talk about about cruises so
Carol and I like to take cruises um and
we tend to go maybe once a year once
every other year or something like that
and if you've ever taken a cruise you
will notice that it has to it always
goes to a foreign country right so I
took a cruise um a year ago year and a
half ago that went down the east coast
of the United States so it stopped in
New York City it's stopped in norfol it
stopped in Charleston and so on but
guess what what one day we went to
Canada right why did we do that it's
because of the Jones act it's because
all of these cruise ships have crew and
um uh and they're built mostly in
Germany and some other places but
they're not built in the United States
because of this
protectionism and uh and their crew is
often many foreign uh people and
so and so they have to you know the
Jones act causes this sort of natural
situation where you can't simply send a
cruise to those places and come back to
Boston it has to go to Canada um anyways
so I'm happy to answer questions oh
maybe before I wanted to an to address
um a couple of U representative plants
question he talked about military so
another example of the problems of the
Jones one of the um when the Jones Act
was passed one of the one of the um
arguments put forward for it was that it
would help us build up a a a commercial
set of ships that in time of War would
be available for use by the military
right but the problem is because it's
gone the other way right comp because of
no competition the number of ships have
built in the US have declined um so for
example when we went to the war in Iraq
right the US government the the Army had
to ship all kinds of tanks and other
equipment to Iraq so they had 500 ships
uh moving equipment to Iraq to fight
that war well only two of them if if I
remember right the only two of them were
Jones act chips right Jones act
compliance chips so the idea that
somehow it helps
our our security or our military or what
ever it it's the other way around
because we are not competitive we don't
have us sources of those ships right so
so all that shipping to move the
military to to uh to Iraq took place on
non Jones act ships right so so if we
get competition and it will help our
industry build up think of the
industries we have that are Premier in
the world right
um uh computer
software uh film
making um uh uh Financial sort of
Industries um a lot of those are things
that have light or or no regulation
especially regulation of this sort right
um the the chairman
mentioned um Railroad and and airplanes
and so on so all these things where we
compete are places where we don't have
have things like the Jones act right we
have open
competition and even as he mentioned um
pleasure boats right there's not a Jones
act there plenty of pleasure boats are
built in the US RVs all this kind of
thing right so um so it hurts us
militarily and other ways not helps us
and now I'm happy to answer
question thank you representative
representative cber yeah thanks um
thanks for taking my question um so in
in the very beginning of um your
testimony you spec you said well you
didn't specify but when you referred to
they as being the protected interests or
something in regards to this um can you
specify a little bit more on who is they
oh thank you very much so the way I
understand the Jones act in the ship
building
arena is that um in order
for a ship to move to move goods from a
Us Port directly to to another Us Port
it has to be
constructed in the United States right
so there are a handful of companies that
build ships in the United States for
this Market but as your chairman said
they cost many times more than similar
ships container ships and other ships
built elsewhere well there are a there
are a handful of companies that build
such ships it turns out most of them if
if not all are actually foreign
owned the work you know the the
shipyards and the building and so on is
in the US but they're owned by you know
Swedish they're part of other foreign
owners right so so those are the kind of
people that because they build those
special those ships that meet the the
Jones act they have an incentive to keep
it follow upk you so just to follow up
on that so I mean we can go on about how
they're foreign owned that wouldn't be
the first like I guess industry in the
US that would be have a similar
structure to that I mean technically it
isn't a monopoly let's say um I guess I
just wanted to maybe stress or or ask
ask you like are we sure that are there
any definitive numbers that the our
amount of sh ship building would go up
and that there actually is a direct
interest in doing so if we were to do
this yes thank you for the question yeah
I'm not I'm not saying there's anything
wrong with foreign ownership in
particular it's just that it doesn't
meet the the stated reasons when the Act
was passed right it's sort of the
opposite has has become happened in over
the ensuing Century but
um
so the answer is it's it's not something
that's going to change overnight right
so so building up a large
industry is going to take time and and
there's also a lot of catchup involved
right because you're starting from a
from a low point and and moving forward
so if you're asking me you know is the
number of sh I think the number of ships
built in the US of these types will go
up over time but I can't tell you you
know next year there'll be 10 and the
following year it'll be 20 and then you
know the year after that's that's
unknowable further questions
representative
Jones Thank you Mr chair and thank you
for being here sir
um the uh six Governors they had asked
for a
suspension would would that be a better
word to use instead of repeal because
that that means it doesn't go away
permanently it get it gives you time to
give it a trial instead of just uh and
do some feasibility studies instead of
just pushing it away yes thank you for
the question so I think the um the
reason the governor's letter is written
that way is because it's not they didn't
write it to Congress they wrote it to
the executive branch and the executive
branch does have the authority to repeal
right this is a resolution going to
Congress who could repeal it right so so
it's a different sort of a different
situation I personally don't think I
mean certainly a suspension is better
than nothing right but but I don't think
it's
um I really don't think there's much
question about the harms of of the Jones
act in
representative
buak so you know I have this Johns act
in front of me you know I like the goals
uh you know the acts goals includes
bolstering you know economic and
Military
self-sufficiency ensuring uh the US has
its own Merchant Marine to avoid
dependence on other nations uh its key
Provisions are shipping between us ports
requires cargo to be transported on us
built us owned and US flagged ships
vessels with us
Crews you here to testify against these
goals and how is this aligned with the
current
Administration I mean
president yes thank you for the question
no I wouldn't say I'm necessarily
against the goals the the problem here
is you can put in the front of any piece
of legislation what your goals are but
the question is does the method of the
of the legislation end up Meeting those
goals and I would argue in this case it
did not right so so we would like it
would be nice if there's a a robust US
ship building industry and if um us
seamen uh were employed in moving Goods
back and forth and things like that
absolutely but but the problem is the
method that that was you know that the
part the bill that the active part of
the bill didn't have that
result so and and I don't have any
special knowledge of you know what the
Trump Administration thinks about this
particular issue so I I can't really
answer that part of the question CH
follow follow up
um if it's
date thank you for the question so I
don't I have the free market I guess is
what I think so so um I think that that
uh light regulation is the way to go in
in competitive businesses all right and
I I think like the examples I cited the
US can do very very well um in
competition we have a lot of innovation
here um we have a lot of smart people um
but protectionism simply doesn't
work further
questions seeing none thank you
representative McGuire we'll let you
return to your committee yes I
appreciate
that okay I'm kind of a butcher on names
but Brian vny did I say that
uh good morning committee members thank
you very much for the opportunity to
testify before you this morning my name
is Brian vahy and I'm vice president of
the Atlantic region for the American
waterways operators awo is the national
trade Association for the tugboat
towboat and barges industry representing
over 300 members throughout the United
States including those serving and
calling on the port of Portsmouth I'm
testifying today in opposition to hcr1 a
resolution calling for the repeal of the
Jones act committee members I
respectfully submit that a vote for HR
hcr1 is a vote against New Hampshire
jobs a vote against strong borders
against military Readiness against
American control over our own supply
chain and AE for Chinese Maritime
dominance the Jones act mandates as
we've heard discussed before uh that
cargo moov between uh us ports be
transported on vessels owned by us
companies built in US shipyards and
crewed by us Mariners our us Towing
industry comprises the largest segment
of the 40,000 vessel strong Jones act
Fleet which plays a crucial role in our
nation's supply chain the US Maritime
industry supports over 650 50,000 jobs
and contributes more than $150 billion
to the economy in New Hampshire alone
the industry generates over $230 million
annually to the state economy and
provides well-paying jobs for New
Hampshire residents as important as the
Jones Act is to America's and New
Hampshire's economy the law is about
more than just its economic impact the
Jones Act is also a vital National
Security asset critical to security ing
our nation's borders and critical to
providing our military with needed
logistical support in peace and in war
simply put without the Jones act foreign
companies subject to control or
influence by Foreign governments would
be permitted to transport vital caros on
our domestic waterways making our supply
chain vulnerable to Serious disruptions
including by China repealing the Jones
act would not only damage all of these
American interests but would do so
without creating any significant
economic benefit for the people of New
Hampshire a December 2023 study
conducted by the National Bureau for
economic research founds found that the
Jones act adds approximately 3/10 of a
cent to each gallon of gasoline yet this
minor increase pales in comparison to
the overall cost of fuel which is
determined by global market factors
moreover the study assumes International
carriers would pass nominal savings on
to customers
but such savings are nearly always
pocketed by oil Traders hcr1 argues that
terminating the Jones act would decrease
fuel costs when in reality the cost of
shipping has virtually no impact on the
cost of fuel for
consumers fuel prices on the World
Market are determined by oil companies
and any transportation savings are
pocketed by energy traders meaning if
the Jones Act is waved it is oil Traders
not consumers and not American Mariners
who will benefit to summarize this
resolution is simply out of step with
the common sense Homeland and economic
security policy that the Jones act
represents we urge the committee to vote
against
hcr1 uh thank you for for your time and
and consideration and if I could just
add one more brief note to my remarks
here um I we've heard some discussion
about uh the Jones act preventing the
the innovation of the US flag Fleet and
I would like to um emphatically state
that that is not the case um that uh the
US uh as I as I noted the US Maritime
industry contributes billions of dollars
to the American economy and that
includes in in modernizing its its Fleet
um we we see we we've heard uh
representative Maguire I believe it was
mentioned Puerto Rico I'll use that as
an example uh the very first ever LNG
powered containership is a Jon act
vessel meaning it was built in the
United States owned by a us Company
crewed by us Mariners uh we've had a
number of awo members so Tugboat and
Barge companies uh that have been making
investments into wind development so we
we proudly consider us Maritime to be a
very modern and
modernizing uh industry that is is is
doing what needs to be done to meet uh
the the very unique energy challenge es
facing the nation as we look to the
Future so appreciate the opportunity to
just add that thank you thank you for
your testimony any questions
representative
gagy thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question uh you mentioned New
Hampshire employees employed in the
maritime uh are they uh working on
oceangoing vessels or just Tugboat
operators barge operators there's there
would be there would be a mix and I
apologize I don't have the specific data
for each industry but a number of those
uh a number of New Hampshire residents
engaged in the maritime Industries would
be engaged working on International
vessels but also working uh for for
Tugboat and barges uh we have a member
company Moran Towing corporation that
has ship assist operations in Portsmith
that's the kind of uh that that would be
the sort of local job that awo
specifically represents follow up follow
up thank
you
so you mention like like the Mississippi
River will say they do a lot of barge
traffic right how if repealing the Jones
act how would that affect Tugboat
operators moving barges along the
Mississippi
River well the the the Jones act applies
to to all us us cargo trans
Transportation so any any any company
that's engaged in transporting cargo
from one Us Port to another Us Port is a
jonak compliant vessel so whether
whether that is a a a a tugboat and
Barge unit transp transporting fuel from
say the gulf to uh to uh the midatlantic
to Philadelphia or whether that is uh
whether that's an A tobo and Barge
operation or moving cargo on the
Mississippi those are all Jones act
compliant vessels and that would would
be those would be trade opportunities
that would be open up to foreign markets
if the Jones act were to be repealed
thank you other questions representative
plant thank you Mr Vice chair thank you
for my question thank you for your
testimony um would you agree that the
reason there is little to no liquid
propane ships that are Jones act
compliant is already due to the free
market and that the demand is high
enough domestically to entice US ship
Builders to innovate and produce more
Jones act compliant ships yeah thank you
for the question sir I I I definitely
would agree that Jones act operators are
beholden to some of the realities of the
market one of the challenges that we
that that our member companies have seen
with regard to building up the U the US
Fleet for LNG for LPG for other fuels of
that nature is that there is not um
there's not the consist
y uh there for uh for companies to feel
uh completely confident making those
Investments and so I'll give an example
um in reference to uh the request by uh
New England Governors um for a uh I
believe it was a waiver of the Jones act
for LNG shipments um that's that that
speaks to I think a lot of the
challenges that that us operators are
facing when it comes to making making
some of these inations uh what what we
have found uh States will often do is
look to wave the wave the Jones act in
the event of of an emergency for a
one-time shipment of LNG whereas what
our members are looking for um is an
opportunity to um make significant
investments in the LG Market as an
example um with the benefit of of
long-term contracts Our member companies
want to serve New England's fuel needs
um for for the long term term for the
foreseeable future and when states are
simply requesting what are essentially
oneoff uh deliveries of LNG that makes
the market a little bit more difficult
for um you know for for uh for our
members to uh to engage in without that
long-term stability does that answer
your question sir thank you other
questions uh go to the corner
representative Belta Manion yeah so my
question is kind of like a chicken and
egg thing with that is like is the
demand itself for the the manufacturing
of LG freighter uh being affected by the
fact that they don't need to compete on
this stage because of the protectionism
that's already in place and we have to
import from overseas and it's not worth
the investment right now no I mean I
would say that if there was the
stability of of a longer term contract
um awo member compan companes the the US
flag Fleet would happily make make those
investments in in the LNG Market I think
one of the challenges that we have been
seeing is that there just is not that is
is not that stability and I would we've
been talking a little bit about offshore
wind a lot of the same challenges exist
exist there now they're just uh our our
members uh the the US Fleet is in is in
the the business of making these
long-term Investments and it helps to
that pres bodu Jackie excuse me um it's
not a question it's a request would you
be able to send us the report that you
cited uh from National Bureau of
something I would be happy to do do that
sir representative Lloyd thank you and
thank you for taking my question um in
your opinion um or your organization's
opinion are there part of the Jones act
which might be able or open to be
amended or should everything stay
exactly as is I would say from from our
point of view the the Jones Act is is is
working it's working for American
consumers it's working for American
Mariners um it has broad bipartisan
appeal um at at Federal at the federal
level at the state level um we we would
not we would oppose any effort to repeal
aspects of the Jones act and and as I as
I hoped to to try to emphasize in my
testimony here we we believe any a
repeal of any aspect of the Jones act
would be would be bad for the United
States and would be bad for the the
state of New Hampshire as well further
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimony very good job all right thank
you
all J will now call Andrew stro
I said that
right you are good you have to help me
out with that one do want to get to
it
morning the Jones act and cargo
preference laws work to ensure we have
the necessary US flag capability and US
Mariners during peace time and Readiness
to move sensitive defense material
during a National Emergency we rely on
Commercial cap capabilities that enable
Department of Defense joint power
projection and highlight the Strategic
nature of our shipyards in SE ports as a
reason why investments in Grant programs
like the port infrastructure development
program are essential in expanding TR
Transportation nodes and
capacity that's a quote from the
fourstar general who is the commander of
the United States Transportation command
my name is Andrew schel I am not the
fourstar general in charge of the
transportation command I am an attorney
I live in uh do New Hampshire I operate
my Law Office in downtown Dover New
Hampshire I'm a graduate of Maine
Maritime Academy and the president of
the Alumni Association uh I held the
master Mariners license of unim tunage
and I was a Jones act Mariner I also
worked on cargo ships for military sea
lift command and I provided food Fuel
and ammunition uh to warships at Sea I'm
here uh to speak in opposition to hr10
uh in effort to repeal the Jones
act a recent study from the National
Bureau of economic research found that
the Jones act adds
0.003 cents per gallon to a cost of
gasoline in New
England Maritime transportation is by
far the most environmentally friendly
way to move cargo trucks create 1,000%
more emissions than Maritime Freight to
move the same amount of cargo the same
distance trains create about 30% more
emissions than Maritime
Freight a marine Vessel can move one ton
of cargo 675 miles on one gallon of fuel
as compared to 475 M by rail
and 151 miles by
truck according to a recent study
prepared by Price Waterhouse Cooper for
the transportation Institute there are
1,210 domestic martime jobs throughout
New
Hampshire related labor income total
approximately
700 m75 million annually in New
Hampshire the total economic impact from
the domestic Maritime in activity in New
Hampshire is nearly
$237 million
annually a study of the American ship
building by the US Maritime
Administration under the Department of
Defense or Department of Transportation
covering both Commercial and Military
ship
construction identified approximately 91
million in annual Shipyard economic
impact in New Hampshire
and more than $61 million in worker
income is attributed to the shipyard
industry in the state Shipyard jobs tend
to pay higher wages approximately 45%
higher than the a national average for
private sector
employment nationally the domestic
Maritime industry accounts for
approximately 650,000 jobs $ 41.6
billion in labor
compensation 15 $4.8 billion in economic
output and $16.8 billion in taxes there
are more than 40,000 vessels in
America's domestic Fleet which is one of
the largest in the
world the Mariners that are working on
the vessels that you've heard about uh
are credentialed by the US Coast Guard
they're American citizens uh that are
overseen by the Coast Guard and have
stringent standards to obtain
and uh maintain those credentials
whether they be working on deck or in
the engine room of these vessels or or
they're the the licensed officers on the
vessels uh those Mariners are the ones
that are bringing dangerous flammable
cargos in and out of our ports and
specifically in and out of the port of
New Hampshire going up to piscatqua
under the bridges that we drive over
most
days uh
earlier we heard a discussion about
repeal amend or suspend the Jones act
the Jones Act is the Merchant Marine Act
of 1920 it's 105 years old it's been in
place there's been amendments but it
stood uh in has bipartisan support and
has
historically uh we also heard about ship
building um in New England um it's my
understanding that Bath Iron Works which
was brought up earlier they specialize
in building warships they build
specialized uh Navy destroyers up in
bath up on the kbec river there are
multiple small uh shipyards that build
tugboats small cargo ships and fishing
boats uh specifically in Maine but in
New England and those are uh domestic
jobs with specialized domestic
Labor uh I also heard discussion earlier
about Cruise Lines uh this summer
Portsmouth enjoyed the opportunity to uh
invite the cruise liner American Cruise
Lines which is a jonak compliant and
passenger vessel uh Services act
compliant uh Cruise Line means it's US
flag US own us crude and they were going
in and out of pment this
summer uh as far as military cargo uh
International military cargo does not
necessarily have to go on Jones at
compliant vessels but it's going to go
on vessels that are us owned uh us
flagged with us Crews that are moving
that uh military material whether it's
uh food fuel ammunition um or what is
required by the Department of Defense to
be moved domestically and
internationally uh and uh recently as
we've just rolled into a new
Administration the uh during his
confirmation hearing the department of
uh Transportation secretary Shan Duffy
uh shared his support for the Jones act
during his confirmation in the
Senate that is the end of my testimony
and I welcome any questions thank you
questions yeah thanks for taking my
question um I actually thought of this
when you were mentioning Coast Guard um
how the Coast Guard you know whatever
they approve folks um under the Jones
act um for Mar for being Mariners um but
um we know that you know as much as we
try to stop it that also like drugs can
come in through obviously through the
waterways is one major way um how how
would this affect that like um repealing
the Jones act could that affect that and
in what way are you aware of
possibly I'm not aware specifically of
of how
uh influx of uh drugs and illegal cargo
could uh be affected by the Jones act
however uh Jones act Mariners are going
to be US citizens they're going to uh go
through background checks in order to
obtain a credential and maintain a
credential so much much like you would
see a TSA agent at the airport and you
know that they are um an employee of the
TSA and they've gone through whatever
background checks required to ensure the
security at the airport uh A Jones act
us Merchant Mariner holding a US
Merchant Marine credential and a
transportation workers identification
credential has gone through a stringent
background check has been overseen by
the US government and uh the Coast Guard
as well to ensure that that person uh
has a clean and clear background so in
that way these Jon act Mariners ensure
that security because they are secure
Personnel operating these
questions pick
one thank you for taking my question um
you gave a lot of statistics about
people who work on the ships and all of
those
numbers so how are you seeing the Jones
act as I'm thinking you're thinking if
With the Jones Act is is
appealed um that these jobs how are you
seeing these jobs going away I'm seeing
it as they would maybe increase but how
are you seeing
it
so
for those jobs the Jones act related
jobs are all US citizens that are
employed on these vessels and and uh
with these vessels so specifically for
someone like me that went to Maine
Maritime Academy and then uh took my US
Coast Guard administer Merchant Marine
officer exams if a shipping company was
not a Jones act vessel if it was a
foreign vessel then I might not be able
to be employed on that vessel um there's
International credentials there's other
uh countries that can employ Mariners
and so if that uh if a foreign uh
company uh could employ a foreign
Mariner over a US Mariner pay them less
not have to ensure um safety and uh and
um security like the US requires of
their Mariners than they might go ahead
and do that and so that would be a
direct loss of an American job uh
employment good employment for an
American family and a a local uh student
that might be coming out of a Maritime
Academy
further questions representative
Jones Thank you Mr chair and thank you
for being here sir thank you
um there's pros and cons to both of uh
repealing the Jones act
um obviously if it is repealed there's
going to be a hiccup in the water
transportation
industry
and T as we know in this world timing is
everything and with
things coming out of Washington right
now such as uh we don't know where
international trade is going on
especially with tariffs and so on and uh
we want to become less dependency on
foreign oil is is the timing wrong right
now to
this in response to your question sir I
I believe the timing will always be
wrong to repeal the Jones act however
ever uh one thing that I I've learned is
that the Jones act does bring stability
especially to uh States and um
protectorates of the United States that
rely on US flag vessels for instance
Hawaii
uh food fuel uh that go to and from
Hawaii go on Jones act vessels if the
Jones Act were to be
repealed then Hawaii would have to rely
on foreign vessels to uh stop by and
bring them their food and some of their
fuel if a us if a foreign vessel did not
want to do that or wanted to charge an
exorbitant amount of money to ship to
Hawaii then the people of Hawaii would
be reliant on that service uh
additionally um we have United States
does have designated services that
service islands like hoi and so with
what you might call just in time
delivery you might be drinking one
gallon of milk and your next gallon of
not uh your next gallon of milk might be
on that cargo vessel and a uh
refrigerated container on its way to
Hawaii from the mainland so that your
next gallon of milk
uh is on its way if you didn't have that
reliability then you don't know where
that next gallon of milk is coming from
just as an
example further
questions representative Lloyd thank you
and thank you for taking my question I'm
going to ask you the exact same question
I've been asking others um in your
opinion um especially as someone who has
worked in the maritime community and
done as much as you have um
are would there be any opening for
amending the Jones ACT versus repeal or
should it stand as is in your
opinion it has stood as is for 105 years
however um I think
if that it's a piece of legislation so
it's always open for Amendment if there
were amendments put forward that uh
would benefit uh the US people uh the US
Merchant Marine and ensure the stability
the security uh and the economic um
benefits then I
believe an amendment would be uh open
and
appropriate I'll take two more questions
we have any more questions
representative minion thank you Mr chair
thanks for taking my questions uh I've
heard twice now that quoted .3 cents per
gallon for gasoline do you guys have any
figures for uh
LNG I I did not have that uh available
to me uh I do have the CIT
and I believe you'll receive that uh I
delivered it with my testimony the price
per
gasoline any
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimony thank you very much and now
card Richard yeah there we go Mr got
he could make out the b on the pink card
that's why I was getting confused sorry
well thank you sir and I want to
apologize for the breach of protocol
Andrew and I went to the same Academy so
I was trying to get a picture so I can
Association and I do apologize I had my
tie with me but I left it in the parking
lot and I walked here and I don't have
my Bean boots so I wasn't going back to
well uh good morning chairman members
I'm going to read my my statement and
then I look forward to some questions
because I have worked on every single
one of these issues that was brought up
today and in a very uh very detailed way
and so I think I can help bring some
perspective to to this uh today I speak
in opposition of hcr1 calling for the
repeal of the Jones act as a former New
Hampshire resident and dual licensed
Mariner
I worked aboard the iconic tugboats in
Portsmouth Harbor as a three combat tour
veteran of Iraq and
Afghanistan and a retired US Navy
Captain also as the former deputy
Maritime administrator appointed by
President
Trump I hope my perspective adds and
helps
you the Jones act has enjoyed bipartisan
support in New Hampshire and in
Washington for many years as a former
Trump appointee I am especially pleased
that President Trump recently shared a
pro Jones act oped and his
Transportation secretary Shan
Duffy uh mentioned support for the Jones
act in his recent nominations
hearings this is all for good reason in
the face of the Chinese Communist
parties escalating Global Maritime
Ambitions and ship building dominance
the Jones Act is our nation's last line
of defense it is critical to Growing our
Maritime sector more importantly it's
critical to maintaining our reserve of
us Mariners to support our deployed
forces who are defending our
nation securing our borders and
protecting us from undue dominance of
foreign
governments though we have a short
Coastline here in New Hampshire it is
still a maritime State we experience 236
million in the maritime industry in the
state and and it affects hous homes
across the
state 1,200 Jobs and 73 million in
wages if the Jones act will repeal today
then New Hampshire would rely on Chinese
shipping
tomorrow and you better believe that
those profits would not be seen here by
our consumers they would go back to
China
there are challenges in the US Maritime
industry but we know what they are and
we know how to fix them it makes no
sense to concede this important Market
to any foreign government repealing the
Jones act would give many New Hampshire
and nation's Maritime Workforce a pink
slip making us even more vulnerable in
Wartime the repeal would off hundreds of
thousands of us jobs to foreign workers
shut down critical Maritime Academy
and devastate our commercial ship
building
industry rather than request a repeal of
the Jones act New Hampshire legislators
should join the Congress and the Trump
Administration in supporting and
strengthening America's domestic ship
building and shipping Industries if we
want to compete with China we need to
secure our borders and we must keep the
Jones
act that's a very brief quick statement
but I am more than happy to talk about
all of these issues
especially two ship building and LNG and
energy to New England cuz I found myself
in the Oval Office being tasked
personally by the president to work on
those issues in the previous
administration chair thank you question
uh representative
gagy thank you thank you Captain I was
in Need for signalman back in the day uh
you mentioned that uh the Jo Act is is
important
um for us because uh it helps with our
security etc etc so if the Jones Act is
so important why are we not building
more ships so that more American crews
could man American Flag ships well sir
that's a good question um and that has
been a problem in the past as I
mentioned that we do have our problems
and in fact if you want to look up ships
for America Act which was just
introduced in the US Senate and the US
House of Representative it has
bipartisan support in both the Senate as
it's been supported as it's been
sponsored by uh Senator Kelly from
Arizona um I forget who the Republican
is and then the same on the house side
and that very piece of
legislation was also co-authored by the
now uh National Security adviser Waltz
um to uh increase ship building in the
United States to increase the size of
our Merchant Marine and to counter the
Chinese threat I think what a lot of
folks maybe may not know in this room is
the the the Chinese are our major
adversary in this industry they are the
largest Builders of ships in the world
they are predatory in the way they do
their business and I'll give you a great
example without using uh the company's
name one of our us shipping companies
was involved in a little fender bender
in a port and had to go to ship your
yard to get it repaired they went to
three different us shipyards to get uh
quotes the quotes came back between
three and5 million to do the repair the
Chinese came to that company and offered
for them to sell the ship to China have
the repairs done and then bring it back
to work in the United States which is
completely legal there's a a vat tax
that has to be paid do you know what the
$90,000 that's not real those are not
real numbers it's because it's so
heavily subsidized and government owned
it's impossible for Private Industry or
capitalistic Society to compete against
that and so that's what we're up against
that's just one example of the types of
things that that are being
done follow up thank you so that was
the ships for America Act yes sir but
more follow up on that it was introduced
in December
uh in your estimation with your
knowledge that you have what's going on
does this act have any legs is it it
does it's an enormous act it's a it's a
it's a an attempt to fix uh Decades of
um neglect within our own Maritime
industry uh so it's it's taken a big
bite out of the Apple but I I think what
we'll see is portions of it will be
taken and put into to the next uh uh
National Defense authorization act
because itself as a piece of legislation
is so it's it's so encompassing that
it's it's going to be difficult to push
through the Congress and the Senate uh
as a whole and that's just my personal
opinion further
questions Madam clerk thank you and
thank you for taking my question same
exact question for you as I've asked
everybody else um in your opinion given
your history and and what you've worked
on um would would amending the Jones act
be a potential possibility instead of
repeal or would that should it stay as
is well uh it should stay as is but but
let me explain that what what what
hasn't been talked about here today is
the Jones Act is not just this one
strict law that says you can't do this
and you can't do that there are multiple
paths to wave the Jones act for example
if a company comes into the United
States and wants to do heavy lift
operations in our offshore environment
and that that type of ship that can lift
those kinds of loads does not exist in
the US Fleet then they can quickly apply
for a us uh non-availability waver the
maritime Administration and the
Department of Homeland Security issue
that and then they can go work and
that's a foreign vessel working in our
ports to the LG issue there are already
two waivers on the books for companies
to come in and take uh foreign ships to
take uh Fuel and bring it to New England
with one stipulation they have to ref
flag to the United States uh and the
reason that hasn't happened is because
there is no long-term Market I worked on
this very issue for a lot of months in
my first term in the Trump
Administration and the problem is Neo
has regulations that will not allow
fossil fuel companies to enter into more
than a six- week contract to provide
fuel to the region the pipelines are
tapped out as was mentioned the storage
capacity is tapped out I had companies
like shell accelerate energy all willing
to ref Flag ships to come in and service
this Market because the letter I think
uh representative Jones mentioned for
the six Governors that sent it to the
president that's why I got called in and
the president said find us a solution we
brought multiple solutions to the table
multiple companies to the table in the
end none of them could do it because of
the of the uh inability for the region
to enter into long-term contracts but I
do have some good news the first ref
flagged LG carrier has been purchased by
Crowley Maritime and is currently in the
shipyard right now being prepared to
enter US flag and will be able to to
service Puerto Rico will be able to
service New England if the need is come
comes
up further
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimony thank you sir and with no
hcr1 yeah right I I went no I want to
keep
it I looking at that again and and I
forgot you gave I said and then I you
this
doing and I
have yeah we got I they'll probably be
coming
yes
um yeah for S you
head
okay thank you Mr Vice chair great job
uh shepher that measure through uh we
will exact we plan to exact uh all these
measures this afternoon that's the plan
that's the hope uh we'll see how things
go we have one more hearing this morning
on hr12 and we have one this afternoon
on
hcr1 uh repres of Jones I hope you don't
take the repeal of Jones act personally
it's just a coincidence that
uh that we have a Jones in our committee
uh nothing personal of course
[Laughter]
so I also want to point out I it might
have been the deputy ranking member it
asked about changing the wording and we
we did put in a request to OS for a
slight wording change in response to
your uh your input so that will be
hopefully forthcoming this afternoon if
if OS can can get to that FYI
okay at this
time uh we want to go to
hr12 which is urging Congress to amend
the Smith month modernization Act of
2013 and the prime sponsor uh is from
this committee representative belshire
and I know there are perhaps hundreds of
people watching at home who want to know
more about the Smith Mont modernization
Act of 2013 so welcome I'm sure that uh
you can uh inform on inform everyone on
that thank you chairman Moffett and
thank you members for having me here to
introduce another bill the good news
I'll tell you is we're probably going to
get back on track TimeWise shortly they
shouldn't take too long first of all
this bill resolution um was the result
of our work in the covid-19 efficacy
investigation committee
from last year this was one of the
recommendations that came forward from
the
committee so the Smith Mont act existed
for much of modern American history and
it contained in it a very important and
unique provision that prohibited the
federal government from propagandizing
the American
people this was a Prohibition on using
the sort of techniques of information
Warfare and propaganda that we utilize
in the state department federally and in
the
military on other countries there was a
Prohibition on propagandizing American
citizens this law was amended by the
Smith month modernization Act of
2013 and critically in that act the
prohibition on propagandizing the
American people was removed
the result has been quite
dramatic we have seen through various
sources on both sides so this is really
not even a partisan thing we've seen on
both sides of the matter problems cut
Downstream from this we've learned from
the mainstream media in various articles
we've learned from the so-called Twitter
files even the work of the newly minted
Department of government off efficiency
at the federal level that's currently
exposing a lot of interesting funding
that has happened under uh USA and and
some other
organizations what we are learning and
what we have found is that billions and
billions of dollars of federal tax money
has been
expended through various media sources
and on various information Warfare
campaigns that have utilized even jok or
the joint um Special Operations Command
and their psychological warfare
divisions to affect Americans perception
of various things that have happened in
our country's recent history not not at
all limited to but including things that
occurred under the covid-19 pandemic
there were influence operations that
were undertaken under various names
utilizing things such as nudge Theory
and other items to change the way
Americans viewed and thought about items
including the source of
covid-19 the safety and efficacy of
various
treatments who or what uh people or
countries might be responsible for what
happened there were information Warfare
and propaganda campaigns undertaken with
American Funds by the American
government against American
citizens and all of this is Downstream
from the Smith month modernization Act
of
legal so this is a fairly simple
resolution that asks Congress to re
amend this act to
reinsert that longstanding prohibition
on using taxpayer funds using the state
department using the military to
propagandize and conduct information
Warfare campaigns against the American
people on us soil it's not something
that should have ever been done it was
we really need to fix it thank you I'll
take
questions thank you representative
belshire you preempted a question that
came to my mind as I was reading the
resolution and listening to your
testimony
with regard to us
Aid uh that's hugely in the news the
last couple days and it relates to do
and in that effort in DC currently and
apparently us Aid has been uh directing
many millions of dollars to the likes of
political uh presumably to influence
press coverage so my first question is I
is with regard to when you submitted
this because is very timely extremely
timely I think but this is not something
you just put in this week so for people
who don't understand the process for
putting in uh bills or resolutions or or
HRS or
hcrs when did you submit this to to the
uh OS process thank you and that's a
very good question um so you may or may
not be aware that in the last house term
uh our speaker uh created a new
committee to investigate the state's
response to covid-19 to figure out what
happened what was done good what might
have been done better and it was through
that investigation that I was a part of
and had the um the pleasure of being
able to author the report on mostly uh
we were able to
learn about the these sorts of things
other things as well but the sort of
information Warfare campaigns that took
place and I can say information Warfare
and I can use that word accurately
because they actually used military
assets to conduct some of this
information uh Warfare on us
soil this came to the light of the
committee we felt it was important to as
one of the multiple recommendations of
the committee to move forward with some
kind of a call for Congress to fix this
issue so it stops
um it was a committee uh
effort and this was put in um without
the full knowledge of everything that
we've come to know in the recent times
but with enough knowledge of what had
happened and you brought up the issue of
the funding that has flowed to various
mainstream media Outlets even more
perhaps importantly than the funding is
to recognize the Personnel that have uh
occupied role roles in some of these
major mainstream media outlets in the
time since have come directly from prior
roles in the state department prior
roles in the CIA and prior roles in
Military Intelligence before coming to
occupy those roles in mainstream media
so there's a lot of connections there
again it's all Downstream from smithm
and that's where we need to fix
this representative the committee you
sub you referred to that the speaker put
together that was presumably a
bipartisan committee how how large was
the committee can describe the makeup a
little bit indeed it was I believe we
had a 10- member committee uh so it was
broken down evenly uh partisan Le 5 and
five um we met a couple dozen times I
believe took um dozens upon dozens of
hours of expert testimony on various
subjects uh and we put together a fairly
comprehensive report that was
published around November of last
year did you say you met a couple dozen
times did I hear that correctly I
believe it was I believe it was at least
an excess of a dozen times maybe maybe
two dozen times we met quite a lot we
met basically every Friday for the
better part of a
year thank you other questions for the
prime sponsor representative Manion
thank you Mr chair thanks for taking my
questions uh uh you mentioned a lot
about the covid-19 but it's highly
likely would you uh agree that it's
highly likely that this could be used to
spark a you know propaganda war against
weapons of mass destruction for a
military invasion of some country under
false
pretenses uh in indeed it could and as
part of our um our research as a
committee and as part of my personal
Research into the sorts of things that
have occurred we actually know that um
the state department and Military assets
have been utilized in public influence
information campaigns uh around more
recent events such as the war in Ukraine
that has tragically perhaps resulted in
already other questions representative
gagy thank you Mr chairman thank you rep
for taking my question uh I need a
little point on line six here um you in
quotes nudge Theory could you explain
what nudge theory is yes thank you so
nudge theory is a concept that comes out
of um Research into psychological
warfare and psychology generally that
suggests that people are manipulable in
their
beliefs by undertaking small incremental
steps of information change this is
something that we know was uh undertaken
specifically because of information that
came out of uh especially Britain under
their I believe it's MI6 Intelligence
Division they work Clos with uh some of
the founders and proponents of nudge
Theory and they were also involved with
um along with our state department and
jck in conducting nudge Theory campaigns
using subtle information shifting um and
framing uh in media and um paid
information campaigns on the internet
things other questions representative
cyber
so I have a question too because we're
talking also about corporate media here
and as we know there are a lot of well a
couple meain corporate media Outlets who
are um definitely a huge part of and
while practicing their Amendment rights
to you know free speech and all that
though that are effectively doing what
this is you know aiming to stop and
quite honestly it doesn't stop them not
saying this this resolution is bad in
any way but should we not go further
into trying to stop them from doing the
exact same thing on behalf of the
government but without the government's
approval thank you for the question and
that's a very important distinction to
bring up and talk about
because what we're talking about is in
the original Smith month act it was a
Prohibition on the state department and
Military from conducting propaganda
operations against Americans
and what is propaganda you can you can
reasonably Define propaganda as any
information effort taken to attempt to
change somebody's views about something
well every op-ed in history that's ever
been written is therefore reasonably
defined as propaganda and that's okay
because individual citizens and
corporate entities that are not
government have rights to free speech
freedom of Association and these things
they can even go so far as to say things
that aren't true and as long as they're
not violating laws against defamation or
the other very specific carve outs for
free speech there's really not much we
can do about that lawfully but it's a
very different um issue entirely When
government gets involved because
government is by necessity a massive
coercive apparatus it has a monopoly on
violence so when the government decides
that it has not just the Monopoly on
violence but also is the Arbiter of
Truth now you have the only entity with
the guns and the means and Taxation too
by the way so they can forcibly take
money from people you have the only
entity with all of those things now
deciding what is true and false and
operating in the information space to
try to make everyone else believe what
is true and false according to it so
it's a very different thing because
government simply put government doesn't
have free speech rights people have free
speech rights so we can't really go any
further with this than saying government
representative the Smith month
modernization Act of 2013 obviously was
named after some Congress people do you
know who Smith and Mt were I must
confess that I I do maybe maybe I'm not
the only one who doesn't remember who
they were do do you know thank you I
honestly I would have to do a search
because that's well before my time
because actually the smithm
modernization ACT amended the original
Smith Mont act which if I'm not mistaken
dates to sometime in the early uh 20th
century right thank you for that I was
wondering if if it was a bipartisan uh
combination I but that's something we
can find out just curious uh
representative cyber kind of have a
followup to my other
question
um would you believe that there is a
possible need
for propaganda on behalf of the Govern
government to be used if said lies um by
the people that the very second
amendment laws
protect um that those lies can cause a
national security risk and therefore
based on a lie would there would need to
be propaganda come behind
that thank you and and that's a good
question and that's some of the line of
argumentation that was um relev in the
initial taking away of that prohibition
toward government propaganda what I what
I would say is there is unfortunately no
perfect solution to false speech the
only uh the best solution is to have a
an Open Marketplace of ideas where
people are free to say things that are
both true and false and hopefully the
truth will rise to the top as people can
demonstrate things to be false because
things that are false can often be
demonstrated to be false the problem is
when government gets involved in that
effort explicitly to try to demonstrate
something is what is true the government
is necessarily taking a side in
something and sometimes it would be a
side I like sometimes it' be a side I
wouldn't like but in any case because it
has exclusive power to violence
exclusive power to taxation it can then
take that mandate for deciding what is
true and what is not and take tax money
as we have now seen to begin to assert
information uh environment control by
placing persons various places in
mainstream media in New Media and
running these operations that really
have the ultimate effect of muddying the
waters so much that one of the
unfortunate things we are seeing I think
is that a lot of people simply don't
know what is true and false anymore
repr if I could follow up on
representative cyber's
point I I'll point out that during World
War II the government funded a Why We
Fight uh series of films and news reals
that had received widespread
dissemination uh all over the country
and beyond our borders uh Ronald Reagan
was an actor who was part of that effort
I
believe so would
you would you think or do you believe
that the use of government funds to
support I guess you could call it
propaganda uh somewh I suppose the the
Why We Fight series that made the case
for people who going to war for people
and families who whose loved ones are
going in times away why are they going
to war well that was the point of the
Why We Fight series
so do you would this preclude or let me
ask you put it this way do you think it
was wrong for the government to to uh
put out the Why We Fight
series thank you for the question I
would have personally mixed feelings on
it just for my personal perspective
because on one hand I I'm not
necessarily opposed to such things as a
general patriotic education and things
like that um on the other hand there is
opportunity there for some malfant
however it's application to this in
particular I can tell you during that
period of time when that video was
released the original smithm Act was
already in place and it did not prohibit
the release of that so this change would
not in fact I don't believe prohibit
that sort of thing what it does prohibit
is utilizing these sort of explicitly
information Warfare and propaganda
assets I mean as a committee who deals
with Veterans Affairs we should all have
a basic concept that there are
psychological warfare divisions in the
United States military that
undertake uh strategic deception and
other goals in order to try to win and
when those kind of assets are turned
against the American people that's where
we get into some really dangerous
territory sure they're called scops and
that is part of military strategy some
will say scops take place in other
venues to include uh I I won't go there
questions uh representative Lane welcome
thank you um I'm I'm substitute as you
well know uh and thanks for taking my
question um I guess info Warfare is such
a
broad term can you give me maybe two
examples in during the covid thing that
you think that you think of as info
Warfare sure thank you for the question
so Jo off the bat in information Warfare
it is it sounds like something that can
be nous term but it is actually
something that's reasonably well defined
within military Doctrine and includes
you know strategic deception toward uh
affecting certain goals uh things that
would qualify or or did happen under the
guise of covid include um significant
efforts that were piped from uh this is
just actually I'll give you one really
good example this is this is ideal so
when was a lot of confusion over the
initial covid uh appearance and trying
to figure out where did this come from
what happened here there was immediately
a roll out from certain elements within
the US government um within certain
areas such as the uh the NIH uh DARPA
was involved who realized that there was
actually potentially some ties to the US
Military and having funded possibly some
of the research that that preceded this
whole situation that occurred and
immediately we and we know this
definitively because of the emails that
have been received from these various
departments immediately there was
efforts to reach out through various
actors including through State and other
departments to contact their mainstream
media sources to push this concept that
covid-19 originated in a wet Market as a
result of some animal incident that
happened in in muhan China and they they
they immediately sought the down play
any possibility that this had anything
to do with a laboratory leak because
they knew that within their files they
had actual um uh proposals that were
written to create and do the gain of
function research on the Corona virus in
question that would come to light if
that Wuhan lab uh story broke and they
were able to chase down well where that
you know where does that lead us so
there was an immediate information
Warfare effort to deceive the American
population to where covid came from
because people within our own government
knew that they may have had a hand in
funding the creation of that
virus other
questions seeing No Hands uh and and
having no other pink cards do we have a
pink card for the prime smer I do not uh
if if you haven't done that
representative if you could because
that's the right thing to do thank you
for introducing this uh before I gel us
out of session here out of hearing mode
uh I want to point out that this
afternoon we have our final measure the
16th of 16 that this committee has been
tasked with it's the hcr1 on climate so
that will commence at 1:00 1300 hours
and that's the only one that we have uh
I my sense is there may be some u in
fact I know there will be some testimony
coming coming in on that uh I am the
prime sponsor so I will not have the gav
the the vice chair as he did this
morning will will wield the
gavel uh if it does go as late as 3:00
just no way of knowing uh we we will be
exec uh try to trying to exec all of our
measures this afternoon that we still
have left of which there will be seven
so the the red team the the Republican
side will caucus at
12:50 at 10 minutes to 1 briefly uh or
let let's say uh quarter to one uh 12:45
an hour from now in the uh in in the
committee office right next door I'm not
sure if the blue team repres
cyber people want to go grab their lunch
we've reserved the room 4013 up there on
the fourth floor in this building um so
if you want to grab your lunch come up
there we can cockus over lunch sound
good okay sounds good to me
representative we did not make a
reservation so we're going to pack
ourselves into the committee room so
that was good for good foresight on your
part so with that uh we'll see everybody
back here at 1 after we caucus and also
one other point because we have the one
measure this afternoon i' I'd like to
make time for at least a five minute
caucus uh again uh for the red team and
the committee office uh to just talk
about our final measure that we'll have
a hearing on this afternoon at cr1 so uh
approximately a 5 minute caucus or
longer if it goes that way and then
we'll come back and we'll ex run exec
session right after
that uh thank you much and we'll see you
hour
e
good okay it is uh 1300 hours plus a
couple minutes so we will uh get
started okay hcr1 is our last of 16
measures for this committee so we'll go
to the hearing before I uh turn the
gavel over I'll just point out that
after we complete the hearing on acr1 uh
when rep Ron the vice chair acting chair
uh ends once we're done with testimony
representative Jon from gone welcome uh
you can have a seat right there and I I
do want to welcome our our subs uh which
we have again today representative Dolan
is back uh representative Dolan sitting
in for representative lungren welcome
back representative Jon from gtown uh
has testified here before on a veterans
Bill welcome back representative Lane uh
good to see you uh you've already
participated already today and uh
represent hardnet
welcome if you have any questions
representative Bennett's right there for
you all right uh so we'll go to the uh
our final measure um as I said I'll turn
this over to the vice chair because I
happen to be the prime sponsor uh a
couple housekeeping notes whenever we
finish with this and I I don't see a a
whole lot of pink cards so everybody
should have time to say what they'd like
to
say uh when the uh Vice chair gavels
the the uh hearing to close we'll have
one final caucus uh period uh I know we
just caucused at lunchtime but the red
team uh will again uh for five minutes
or so just to go over this last measure
uh in the office area in Madame ranking
member whatever you'd like to do with
your folks uh yeah we'll do a mini
caucus too uh do it out theall or okay
uh however you do your mini caucus uh
I'm sure you you'll you'll be good to go
and then and then after that we will
come back in and uh we will if we can we
will exact uh our seven remaining uh
measures I'm sure that the folks at OS
will be watching on TV hoping we finish
before five I think I think we will hope
we will I know they hope we we do too
and then that that'll do it for us uh
hopefully until crossover represent s uh
are are you going to put in a pain card
okay uh we do as our customers try to
give deference to um uh legislators who
are who take the time to Comm in
so the
sequence okay and I'll turn the gavl
uh representative Moffett Prime
sponsor on
up oh wait a minute yes sorry about that
okay there you go get after
me opening the hearing on hcr1
represent M go ahead good thank you
representative Rollins get right to it
um this is largely a resolution about
freedom of speech and about
fairness it simply states that we should
listen to all sides when forming policy
in this case climate policy is lawmakers
who deal with climate related bills
shouldn't we listen to all sides
shouldn't we listen to all sides for any
Bill uh it's also as I see it as the
sponsor see it as an
anti-bullying uh resolution s seriously
and I'll I'll explain that uh there are
those of us who feel that the climate
alarmists have long been overly
successful in defining climate
narratives on on their
terms uh dramatic claims abound uh to
advance those narratives
the chair of our Science and Technology
committee uh not long ago shared a list
of around
50 50 what he referred to as hysterical
climate change claims and predictions
none of which came came true all of
which proved false I won't go through
them here uh but uh they're out there
I'll say no earthquakes are not caused
by climate change uh and no the the many
Canadian wildfire
last year were not caused by climate
change they were they were caused by
arsonists so climate is being blame or
climate change man-made climate change
is being blamed for anything and
everything I'm exaggerating somewhat but
uh that's part of the impetus behind
this
resolution uh and of particular interest
to the state federal veterans committee
would be efforts to force our military
aircraft to use climate friendly but
hugely expensive
bofs uh or to mandate the use of battery
powered tactical
Vehicles then vice president Harris a
couple years ago uh excitedly spoke to
graduates at the Naval Academy about
having Marines carry solar powered
blankets as a former Marine Corps
infantry men myself I'll say that we
make troops and a lot of you know what
I'm talking about we already make troops
carry way too much weight already
without asking to carry solar panels or
batteries into combat situations as well
so when this climate activism threatens
the military procedures and and by
extension National Security I think we
need to take notice many of us think we
need to take notice now we've
heard uh I've heard we've heard many
times 97% of scientists agree we need
climate action
now but many of us feel a need to
challenge that
97% this consensus supposed consensus of
scientists who all agree that uh man is
changing the climate we need to take
climate action
now if a scientist holds a healthy
skepticism about dramatic climate change
claims uh we've seen them labeled as
deniers that's something we hear a lot
about oh you're a climate denier it's
similar to Holocaust denier which is a
pejorative term meaning you're denying
something that is true and shouldn't be
denied and I don't think that people who
have some measure of skepticism about
some climate claims if they have some
questions or Skeptics they shouldn't be
ridiculed or denounced or called
deniers Nobel lauriat Dr John clauser
was going to present a seminar on
climate models to the IMF that's the
international monetary fund who was
taking a look at some climate situations
but he had his talk canell this happens
a lot happens on college campuses
especially people who have contrary
opinions on climate uh get bullied to
include a Nobel laurate who had his talk
cancelled and that concerns me whatever
the position is I I think most of us are
free speech Advocates if any opinion
gets uh squashed
if it gets denounced if it's not allowed
to be expressed that's a threat to
everybody
whatever whatever your position
is in 2023 a list of 16009 uh you can
find this on online
169 renowned scientists Scholars and
others including engineers and and and
others uh 169 people signed a statement
that said quote there is no climate
emergency
16009 so should these 169 views be
discounted and dismissed and uh shunned
uh here in this body we're asked to
impose higher electric rates on granite
Staters so as to subsidize what some of
us feel are are questionable climate
initiatives the climate activists have
succeeded in raising electric rates
that is a fact fortunately and I give
the folks who are experts in this and
Science and Technology committee who
spent a ton of time on this I give them
credit for doing their due diligence and
and and making some of the decisions and
recommend recommendations that they have
vermonts on the other hand in Vermont
they've gone
way radical uh last term in Vermont they
pass measures that are SE seeking to
hold uh energy companies liable for
climate change in
Vermont and the repercussions of that uh
the unintended consequences are manyfold
and and and scary uh Vermont's trying to
walk back this bill the the last
election saw a lot of the people uh
there's a big change in the Vermont
legislature uh last election just this
last November in part du
to some of the bills that they passed
like the one that's going to scare
energy companies out of Vermont because
if they do business in Vermont they're
going to have to pay all this money to
Vermont to fix climate change in
Vermont so I think there's a there's a a
lesson there for
us to pay attention to uh here in New
Hampshire not long ago a bill was
introduced to ban wood stoves in New
Hampshire some of you recall that yeah
some folks are coming after our wood
stoves and it gets cold here in New
Hampshire and that measure did not pass
but that's the type of mentality that we
need to uh acknowledge and and encounter
it gets cold in New Hampshire and so and
activist climate activists are also
working hard to mandate carbon taxes on
our businesses All Over America like
they have in in Sweden France Portugal
and elsewhere California even passed a
law Banning the sale of gas powered cars
after 2035 and there were people in the
granded state who wanted in every state
who want similar measures to be passed
into law to ban the sale of gas
powerered
cars it's all some it's already a fact
in California but they they have 10
years to to get there uh of course I
spent a lot of time in California
climate regulations in California have
pushed gas prices presently you know
five over $5 a gallon I was there last
year and it was some places $6 a gallon
$7 a gallon why is California gas so
expensive a lot of it's due to climate
regulations in that state and who does
that hurt the most when you have $6 a
gallon gas price the the people who can
least afford
it then there are carbon credits and
carbon allowances the United Nations
assigns carbon credit formulas to
various countries who are supposed to
monitor carbon emissions and report back
to the UN organizations can buy carbon
credits and they can even sell them if
they don't use them
all 13 States including most of our
neighbors here in the Northeast have are
involved in they call it cap and trade
programs uh and a lot of you have heard
of uh Reggie the regional greenhouse gas
gas initiative which I New Hampshire has
been able to avoid getting committed to
uh which I I think is good I know some
disagree I would sub submit that Reggie
and
Associated recommendations and and and
demands probably have zero impact on our
climate but it has made electricity as I
said more expensive and inconveniently
many climate activists fly around the
world in Jets leaving massive carbon
Footprints so to counter that they can
plant trees to offset their carbon use
or they can buy forests as has happened
in New Hampshire I'm from Coos County so
one out ofate entities purchased 146,000
Acres of forest up in Coos County up in
the North Country so as to engage in
carbon offsets and selling carbon
credits now these Forest this Forest
land that's been Pur you can't cut those
trees because they're they're part of
selling carbon credits to the to the
people who fly these Jets around and
need to offset their carbon use by
putting our timber in in the North
Country uh out of off limits for
lumbering for Timber
use so ponder that the US has about 4%
of the United or 4% of the world
population and New Hampshire accounts
for less than a half percent of that
population so in my view and many of our
views all the Reggie initiatives and
subsidies and mandates and carbon taxes
and carbon credits that they want to
impose on graned Staters will have Zero
Effect on climate so all the stuff that
that people want to do to us uh is going
to have zero impact so why do we want to
uh adopt policies and pass bills that
like Vermont did like California did
that's going to hurt in my view our view
grand Staters if it if we could know
that it's going to make a difference
that's one thing but if it's pretty
apparent it's going to have zero impact
on climate what are we
doing and it's such a challenge to raise
a Wess about the dangers of climate
extremism when the media the so-called
clean energy Industries lawmakers
alarmists and other activists join
forces to squelch those who question
climate
Orthodoxy so again I said this is also a
bullying measure so I hope we can stop
bullying people who are skeptical of
climate alarmism so this resolution
simply calls for all voices to be heard
and for a fair climate debate I want to
let other folks testify and you know I
know there's other pink cards here um I
want to finish by saying that I some of
you know I write I I it's what I do I I
do a Blog I you've some of you probably
seen I have op-eds and opinion pieces uh
put words together and the platforms the
blogs and daily newspapers have been
very good about using stuff I send them
maybe because it's good stuff or
whatever but uh one local daily with an
exception one local daily paper uh
refused to run something I wrote about
climate now I wrote it in response to
some climate alarmism that I just
thought needed a response to so I tried
to respond and they wouldn't run it they
run almost everything I send them good
stuff apparently except climate and
that's goes to my point about uh some
perspectives
being
denied uh the the title of my piece for
the mon the local paper was uh 14 points
wood Wilson once had 14 points uh at the
end of World War I so I picked out 14
points regarding the climate I could
have picked out 40 but I picked out 14
so because I can and because the paper
didn't run I'm going to take a couple
minutes very quickly and go through
those 14 points number one centuries ago
during a hotter era Viking settlements
thrived on the Greenland Coast
Greenland uh global cooling caused their
abandonment uh in when it got very cold
in Greenland I guess we're back in
Greenland but uh so why weren't those
Coastal communities inundated by higher
sea levels uh during those much warmer
times number two in 1999 climate
researcher Michael man his climate work
was cited all over the world to support
anti-global warming policies his claims
were later repudiated he's a Canadian in
the Canadian court but man the scientist
man refused to share his data or his
methodology and so he lost the case and
had to pay court costs because he
wouldn't support he wouldn't Supply the
methodology to support his claims number
three conspiratorial climatologist
correspondents in the UK included an
email from man Michael man which
chillingly suggested finding a friendly
investigative journalist to expose
skeptical scientists like Steve McIntyre
classic bullying okay McIntyre is a very
highly regarded climate ologist who had
a contrary view so they tried to take
him out they tried to have friendly
media people uh take him on and uh
expose
him IR number four ironically
progressives can be some of the biggest
obstacles to Green energy we just heard
this yesterday in the house floor uh
with regard to uh nuclear power uh
opposing clean nuclear power opposing
clean Hydro power from Quebec and even
cleaner natural gas from out west
number five solar power and windmills
matter but airplanes can't fly on
batteries number six climate extremists
emotionalize things 15 you recall
15-year-old Swedish activist Greta
thunberg person of the year Time
Magazine invited to share her scientific
wisdom at the UN General
Assembly true seven congresswoman
Alexander orazio Cortez led the breakout
of what we feel some of us feel is a
radical Green New Deal uh which was
endorsed by many or most presidential
candidates right look look at what the
green New Deal
entailed frightening to to many of us uh
AOC by the way was a New York City
bartender before she became a climate
expert number eight cowed by a aoc's I
just said many presidential candidates
endorse the green New Deal which would
impose stifling government regulation to
diminish freedom and curtail economic
growth as
legislators we need to to pay attention
to proposals like the green New Deal and
all that goes with it number nine our
climate changes constantly always has
always will but no one can state with
certainty the precise impact humans have
on such change and aside uh I am not a
climate denier I agree the climate
changes always has always will the the
big issue is uh how much
does mankind impact climate change
there's a spectrum of thought on that no
no one can say
precisely uh number 10 uh that humans
can change our climate is is quite
presumptuous a Sports Illustrated piece
on shorter P pond hockey seasons in
Canada proposed that we quote cool our
planet as soon as possible so even
Sports writers are compromised calling
for us to cool our planet uh number 11
almost done uh Mother Nature can indeed
cool the earth a catoa style volcanic
eruption would spew many millions of
tons of Ash into the atmosphere block
sunlight lower temperatures this
occurred a number of times our four
major ice ages many think or due to
massive volcanic eruptions that block
the Sun and then we had ice ages a
little ice age occurred in
1816 a year with summer there was a
massive eruption in Mount
Timor and uh lower temperatures for a
year it's here in New Hampshire it
snowed every month and crops are ruined
this is when people got the heck out of
New Hampshire because they couldn't
raise crops and they moved to Tennessee
wherever it's called 1816 and froze to
death if you want to look that up uh
that cooling happened not because of
mankind it happened because of Mother
Nature and it leads want to wonder if if
mankind is indeed warming the planet
which many claim uh some are skeptical
if we if we are doing that and we warn
the planet by a degree or two would that
temper or counter the next major
volcanic eruption would it save us from
nice stes I don't know just putting that
out there okay number 12 the media
Embrace climate climate change stories
because sensationalism gets attention
but if one does some digging one notes
that many climate op ads are written by
solar or wind power folks who stand to
benefit from mandated reductions and F
fossil fuel use of course the people who
make batteries and so solar panels and
windmills and all that of course it's in
their best interest to scare people and
create a demand for their
products uh number 13 uh scientists get
more attention and more grant money if
there's a climate crisis so of course
it's in their best interest to make the
case we have a crisis and finally number
14 uh political movements this politics
of this of course political movements
need energy and we need to admit that
climate change activism is exploited by
some to Advanced agendas many folks now
associate climate change not just with
earthquakes but with everything else
from cow flatulence to militarism to
racism to sexism related to climate
change uh so the politics of climate
change is very real so uh there's much
more than these 14 points but as censo
said of woodro Wilson's 14 Points even
God had only ten commandments so thank
you I'll stop there the climate is
changing and humans are part of the mix
I just said
that but a measured transition away from
fossil fuels is I think
desirable but a measured transition not
a radical transition and as we move
forward we should make decisions based
Less on bullying and more on reason and
and mutual respect thank you for your
time I'd be happy to take questions if
there are
any
questions represent
cber yeah thanks for taking my question
um I guess um so are you aware that
meteorologists when it comes to bullying
meteorologists or with a doubt on the
Forefront of that when it is their job
to to report on the weather and they
there's essentially a consensus on that
when it comes to meteorologists except
the one who was threatened by their job
on Fox
News so to um stop reporting um and
using the term climate change and yeah
and refers to that so um so I feel like
when there's bullying would you not say
there's enough to go around on both
sides and it's a little unfair to Target
one side about that sure thank you for
the question and comment uh as I said I
bullying whatever the issue is I I I
condemn I want everybody to be able to
give expression and of course here where
we debate and discuss and challenge each
other that's our job uh so we're kind of
used to it here but uh to your point you
mentioned meteorologist now
meteorologists are are weather people
weather men whether WEA reporters uh as
opposed to climatologist and uh and I'll
Grant uh I I read up on this somewhat
and a preponderance of
climatologists seem to have given
expression to the belief that man cause
climate change is an issue and I I I
respect their opinions and they they may
be correct but to my earlier Point
whether it's meteorologists or
climatologists uh having back and forth
there's a spectrum even amongst
meteorologists or climatologists they
don't all agree precisely on how much
mankind or humans humankind impacts the
uh the climate so uh I I take your point
and I think it's fair to expect uh you
know people to give some due deference
to experts meteorologist climatologist
while acknowledging that they don't all
agree and consensus is not a scientific
term consensus is when most people get
together and they pretty much agree in
general uh but that's not how science
Works science is very specific and uh
you can have data and conflicting data
and it's a consensus i' be careful about
science further questions representative
Jones Thank you Mr chair if it's okay
thank you for presenting this
representative uh most of our our
resolutions finish up uh with the last
line saying who they want to go to and
this doesn't say anything it does do you
want it to the federal New Hampshire's
Federal delegation do you don't want it
to go to the Full House and Senate do
you want it to go to the
president thank thank you represent it's
a great question uh it's a concurrent
resolution we would have to go to the
Senate and if it if it did pass both
bodies uh then it would be incumbent on
the uh leadership of both bodies to
share that and that's something that
this if it passes the sponsors would
take it take the initiative to make sure
that it was shared with the federal
delegation uh I I agree I think it would
have been better like many other
resolutions to specifically state that a
copy would go to uh the who or whatever
so uh so it's going to be up to the
supporters to uh uh promulgate this if
it passes okay I just want to know who
we were writing to thank
you other
questions represent representative
Manion thank you Mr chair thanks for
taking my question so are I've been
reading a lot of these studies I don't
know if you have uh but there's some
talking about like the climate anxiety
with the upcoming generation would you
say that we should not be legislating uh
the fear into the the children for
things like this thank you for
mentioning that rub some Manion I was
going to mention that and I I already
had too many words um but kids are being
scared to death uh there there's all
kinds of anecdotal and statistical
information you know youngsters today
growing up this is hovering over their
head the world's going to the world is
in danger uh there's a climate crisis uh
we're all going to die uh and I I'm I'm
being a little bit uh hyperbolic but not
much that's a great Point that's a
concern that I'm glad you brought up
because uh we're scaring our kids and
and that's something that we need to be
uh representative Lane um thank you and
thank you for taking my question I just
wanted to you had mentioned
yesterday's um Bill about the definition
of clean energy and I just wanted to
remind and I have to do this in a
question but when representative mcke
spoke on the floor she made it very
clear that she was not voting against
nuclear energy and wanted it to be
included what she W do you recall what
she said she was concerned
about yes I thought that was a very good
exchange yesterday uh representative
McGee explained her concern with what
was trying to move forward and she was
not opposed to nuclear power uh but if
you can go ahead if I can M Mr Vice
chair if I can ask her to make sure that
we're clear on on the point there that
what was said yesterday in the house
floor sure
and my recollection and again it's a
recollection is that she wanted to have
she regretted that did not have time to
work on a better definition and wanted
it and was not happy that we were in the
position of having to change it on the
floor and she did not want anything
that's usually considered to be a quote
um I don't know if it's low emissions or
dirty emissions I'm not an expert but
she did not want that in included in the
definition and was hoping that they
could reach a better to use the other
word consensus on the um definition
that's my recollection of the gist of
what she was saying would you say that
that's an incorrect no I think you
characterized it pretty well I I thought
represent McGee and and the chair
represent Vos were both very good at
explaining their perspectives I thought
they were both very uh uh knowledgeable
to feel they're both in Science and Tech
energy and uh yeah so I guess my point
in mentioning that this came to the
floor yesterday uh and I don't want to
have that misconstrued the my greater
point was that even yesterday we were
talking about the the uh issue of
nuclear power being clean energy and I'm
trying to think of the terms are used as
clean uh uh I'm trying to remember the
two terms uh that they were talking
about but uh yeah my greater point was
just that we were talking about it and I
I think both I think the world of both
represent G representative votes and and
and I thought was a very interesting
exchange and and uh and a good vote in
questions oh yep sorry representative
Duan
sorry thank you uh and thank you uh for
taking my question um in order to
maintain a healthy level of skepticism
don't you think it's natural for
scientists to agree with whoever is
funding them thank you for the question
I kind of touched on that it's a little
bit of a uh that that notion that people
are being bought uh is goes both ways uh
uh I guess the your greater point is is
money influencing some activities and
energy and I think of course uh how much
uh money impacts positions that people
take is there's no way to measure that
but yeah I think uh moneyed interests
they're having a big impact on the
debate yes I agree thank
you any further questions seeing none
thank you representative mafa good job
thank you Mr Vice chair and keeping the
traditions in this in this committee
we're going to ask to have their
representatives come up testify first so
Tim hornan would you come to the seat
and Tim has asked for two minutes and he
I'm representing Timothy Oregon from
straford County District 10 and two
small bits of background is I was a
civilian employed the Army cor cor of
Engineers a number of year working on
climate change issues and the climate
has continued to change since then that
was about and also like I'm I was around
uh I'm old enough to remember well first
of all the Three Mile Island Disaster in
19 in the late 1970s and then also um
the uh fight over the seab brook nuclear
power PL so to get to the uh nuclear
power plants the idea that's clean
energy I mean the technology may have
its place but the idea that's clean
energy is kind of ludicrous uh we really
haven't solved the problem of what to do
with the waste and the other dangers so
it's actually it's a technology that may
have some promise but it's still
extremely dangerous um even if it
doesn't uh release any carbon and the
idea that it's renewable um it's about
the least renewable source of energy
there is so as for the um as for the
climate change yes the climate has
changed dramatically before humans come
along it's changing now and that's
that's a re you know that's just a
reality we only have this one planet the
human race only has this one planet to
live on I know Deputy president mus
wants to make us multiplanetary but that
that's a long way away from country to
fruition I really don't think that can
ever happen certainly not happening now
so you we don't have any there is no
Planet B there aren't any other planets
we can we can go to there's just this
one planet it and we really should be as
careful as
possible possible with it and um
finally um we're talking about the
scientists being uh you know bought out
and it's true you know the funding is
part of it but that's true also for the
fossil fuel companies the only
difference is the fossil fuel companies
they run by corporate Executives so
they're and they do a f fiary interest
to pursue you know the goal of
maximizing shareholder value and I I
will assume that they must I will I
won't necessarily just dispute the myth
that they do so with perfect objectivity
out of the goodness of their hearts but
um so I would just say and also so I
would just say this this resolution the
idea behind it is bad and also like the
way it's drafted we're not really I'm
amazed it even got through the drafting
process because uh we're sending a
resolution to who no one so obviously
this committee if they want to go
forward to it they'll have to either
amend it or rely on the other body to
amend it but the other body has a his
has of not even accepting hcrs so this I
would just say I probably I've already
wasted about 2 minutes might well spent
about 2 minutes of my time talking on it
so I think probably this is not
something that's worth you know a large
amount of the committee's time because
you know we're sending this meaningless
and false resolution based on
questionable premises to who to no one
no one really cares no one's really
going to change what they do based on uh
question go ahead question oh thank you
representative Horgan yeah so if no one
really cares why are you here um I was
actually here for another bill across
the hall about school lunch I mean I did
see this thing and said this is just
wacky like why you know I was amazed
even that it got through the drafting
process and when I was a rookie rep
freshman rep I think I had a resolution
about something and uh the drafter a
wonderful man named Paul Lindstrom who I
think is retired he said well here's
your proposal like you know if you
suppos a resolution you you're supposed
to be notifying someone exhorting
someone you know who is this resolution
directed to and I thought about it and I
wasn't sure so he I agreed that maybe my
idea was bad so I'm this was the same
problem with this proposal when we
brought it into the drafting attorney he
he or she probably forgot to ask um who
are we ex you know who are we directing
this to who are we exhorting who are we
acing action from um you know so that's
thank you thanks uh further questions
representative plans thank you Mr Vice
chair and thank you representative for
being here thank you for your testimony
so you stated nuclear isn't clean energy
due to its waste um it's also finite and
not renewable what do you say to the
waste created for landfills from old
solar panels and massive Abominations we
call windmills um I I I don't think the
windmills or solar panels that bad but
the materials are at least in theory
uh can be recycled more and they're not
uh they're not radioactive the way
nuclear waste is so I I just um disagree
I mean I understand where you're coming
from I know where those talking points
are coming from but I I simply do not
agree with them so and um I think it's
it's a very small problem nuclear waste
I mean n like the cabb nuclear power
plant some of that waste you know we're
going to have to find some
way to wait you know hundreds or even
thousands of years before it the
radioactivity decays to a point where
it's safe to handle and we really um
there really is no particularly good
plan for for dealing with it and
especially if we actually this and
especially if we then begin nuclear
power which has been a fairly small uh
yeah we sort of a dead end in
technological Evolution so if it becomes
a big deal again um you know then we'll
have like exponentially more times that
waste to deal with representative any
further
questions seeing none thank you for
testimony thanks remember we only have
that one planet
so okay next on the agenda is Matthew
Kellan did I say that right and he
supports the bill and is asking for four
minutes good afternoon chair Mofford and
the committee my name is Matthew Kain um
I represent myself today um as a
concerned C citizen I'm currently
self-employed as a health consultant and
teach part-time at Antioch University I
support The Proposal with some a few
suggestions my qualifications is really
a master's degree in public health from
um UCLA um three decades of working um
with state and local offics within state
government collaborating with state and
federal affili on on research um I've
done a few peer- reviewed um
publications related to climate um and
the project um number of projects at a
local level trying to reach out and
trying to help communities adapt to
climate change um I'm concerned about
climate change for a couple different
reasons well first I'm an outdoors
person I can really see the change in
our longer summers U more intense
shorter Winters and certainly the
expansion of of tick habitat and I'll
talk more about that um I believe the
other concern though really as a
scientist I'm concerned about the
misperception of the consensus around
climate change um its causes as impacts
and solutions um more about that I
believe we have a lot of high quality
evidence about the causes of climate
change there's a lot of consensus there
um there's some strong evidence for the
impacts certainly around the idea of
extreme weather events and and uh not
extreme weather events sorry um extreme
heat events um those are that strong um
but there's less strong evidence for
revivable Solutions and I think it's
important to know when we talk about a
consensus around climate change we're
talking about just that first Pete on
the causes and the impacts um and the
solutions to those are still really in
within that s scientific Arena where we
need to explore them more and understand
them so how does climate change um
impact Public Health I worked on it for
10 years through the New Hampshire DHHS
um and the evidence points to kind of
three main impacts um from climate
change in New Hampshire first is Vector
born disease I think we can really uh
demonstrate that because of the slight
warming and because of um more um uh
precipitation um tick habitat has
expanded and tick born disease has done
that some of the best studies look at 10
to 30 % of tick born disease is probably
related to climate change in some way
when I say climate change I mean
anthropogenic climate change right
something is happening because of human
causes um the second main impact is
mental health and somebody's already
mentioned this um climate driven
disasters can lead to short-term mental
stress and also long-term disorders
longer warming seasons and shorter
Winters um also really impact our
outdoor workers um and impact um the
ability of ski industry uh Forestry
Landscaping to do their job and that can
be really stressful on those uh business
people and their workers and finally
climate change has impact on traumatic
injuries um and Heat injury I
co-authored a study with Plymouth State
University peers where we looked at that
we didn't find a huge significant impact
but on those days where we had extreme
events all cause injuries went up that
makes sense in a way right we're
Outdoors we're playing we're working
we're doing things it makes sense how
much of that is driven by climate change
we weren't able to discover in that
research um so in summary you know we're
adapting to climate change and I think
we have we can kind of show that we have
the ability to do that and that's
positive that I think addresses some of
that mental health that there's
Solutions out
there how climate change alarmism
affects Public Health this is something
that isn't talked about much um an
alarmist approach to climate advocacy
can Nega negatively impact Mental Health
and Social Unity gets people it's a very
polarizing issue recent surveys of Youth
only almost 70% across the world
actually said that they are extremely
worried or very worried about climate
change climate researchers and media
reports as people mentioned here often
present the worst case
scenario um and uh climate Africa is
also downplay the known improvements in
environmental conditions we've all
invested a lot in better air quality and
better water quality with real health
benefits um an example is climate has
warmed over the last 50 years but
evidence shows a significant decrease in
heat related deaths especially in our
cities it's getting warmer and we're
doing better the the research is I'm
going to say complicated but some
sometimes contradictory and people need
to know that in addition we've been able
to improve air quality and reduce
pollution related deaths by over 100,000
a year a young people need to hear this
they learn need to learn that history to
improve their mental health gain hope
and be productive members of our society
um how this bill could be improved um I
believe this resolation can be improved
by changing the words fraudulent and
intimidation to more neutral terms even
if those words are accurate in some rare
cases it's like as that cause more
division appear biased and limit
bipartisan
support now how this bill could
encourage better dialogue and maybe less
debate um if this resolution passes both
houses in the Senate I encourage you to
engage with peers from the granite
Bridge Alliance led by representative
Fred plat from g toown New Hampshire
this bipartisan group is dedicated to
Reaching Across the aisle to improve
dialogue I'd be happy to work with this
legislature anybody who wants to work on
that for the issue of climate in closing
this resolution is focused on the topic
of climate shap this it also brings to
light this polarization of our political
views I hope we can use this as an
opportunity to engage in thoughtful
dialogue and move away from that
reactive debate we need more honest
Brokers involved with the climate
dialogue people um who view it as a work
in progress with all the gaps
uncertainty and healthy skepticism that
scientific Endeavors deserve um thank
you for considering my views on climate
information and I'm happy to answer any
questions or address comments do we have
no questions seeing none thank you very
testimony now I'd like to call up
Matthew Kell oh no that's the one I just
did sorry John Gage five has asked for
five minutes and he is opposed to the
bill
uh thank you members of the committee uh
I really appreciate the testimony we
just heard and if significant changes
were made I would support the bill uh
the title sounds extremely reasonable to
me and something that we should be doing
it's the whereas Clauses that I disagree
with one of my handouts goes through
changes that I would
make it seems to me that the New
Hampshire State Legislature is
unwittingly doing the bidding of outof
State polluters this session
some people in positions of leadership
have been tricked by a decades long
two-faced game by an outof State
polluter industry for example one of the
co-sponsors of this bill has attended 16
conferences around the country funded by
a group of fossil fuel billionaires and
free market fundamentalists collectively
known as the coch network their money
funds front groups who are brilliant
brilliant at PR the groups call
themselves conservative think tanks but
in reality they are propaganda outfits
PR firms they hide a rotten core uh for
polluters under a thin veneer of
legitimate conservative values they are
the bad actor face of the fossil fuel
Industries two-faced game to promote
state and federal policies to maximize
the profits of the fossil fuel
industry the good actor face accepts the
scientific consensus about agw anthropo
enic global warming and supports carbon
pricing because as nearly every
Economist agrees it shouldn't be free to
pollute see the second handout I just
gave you for quotes from Major Oil and
Gas um producers saying that they agree
with the science and the threat of their
pollution on our society and why they
support carbon
pricing but the bad actor face as
embodied in the Koch Network funded
front groups down plays climate science
spins and respins long refuted myths
half-truths and even lies to trick
regular people and legislators into
doing their bidding several coch Network
funded front groups paid over
$24,000 to fund the 16 trips the
co-sponsor I mentioned has taken to
their
conferences these groups are brilliant
at what they do it is not shameful to
get tricked by them but it is shameful
to continue Contin to play the game for
years after the Two-Face game has been
brought to our attention members of the
committee democracies die from a
collaboration between the corrupt and
the
ignorant for years I've asked the
science technology and energy chairman
to invite our State climate SC
climatologist we have an official State
climate
scientist to an informational hearing
where his committee members can get
their misunderstandings about basic
climate science straightened out last
week he told me that he would do it on
his terms he hasn't done it yet but if
he had maybe this bill would have been
retracted or or
modified I am alarmed about climate
change I left my job at Oracle full-time
full benefits
career uh because of my concern that I
got reading
science major studies from major
scientific
organizations why am I alarmed was it
from the so-called climate alarmists
this bill refers to no it was my
bachelor's degree in biology from Boston
College two years of working in a
science lab Decades of reading
non-fiction science the abundance of
evidence I've seen personally over my
lifetime combined with that identified
in those major studies and summaries
about human cause global warming from
mainstream scientific organizations
and thinking through all the evidence
presented that led to an acceptance of
the theory of agw as most likely
explanation and there is not a single
scientific organization in the world
that disputes
it the ipcc says in their six assessment
report the cumulative scientific
evidence is unequivocal climate change
is a threat to human well-being and
planetary Health any further delay in
concerted anticipatory Global action on
adaptation and mitigation will miss a
brief and rapidly closing window of
opportunity to secure a livable and
sustainable future for
all climate anxiety was mentioned uh
about our youth we don't want to scare
the youth but they're learning about
science in school they are learning
about the pollution from fossil fuels
causing a long-term problem in their
future hiding this from them is not
doing them a
favor this the language in this bill
would cause climate anxiety in a youth
um downplaying the seriousness of the
problem and uh using language that makes
it sound like taking this matter
seriously is unre
irresponsible James
Hansen said in a newsletter today
special interests have assumed far too
much power in our political system in
Democratic countries the power should be
with the voter not with the people who
have the money that requires fixing some
of our democracies including the
US public sentiment is firmly against
the pro- fossil fuel anti-science
messaging and state bills generated and
promoted by the front groups funded by
the fossil fuel industry in its Two-Face
game of deception for profit at Great
cost to
us the major bills heard by the science
technology and energy committee show the
public online testimony in the hundreds
of people supporting good climate action
and against Bad fossil fuel favorable
bills and every vote by the majority
goes the wrong way against the Public's
uh position on the
matters the major fossil fuel industry
players know about the damages they are
causing but they just don't seem to care
enough to overwhelm the massive profits
they
see this New Hampshire session will make
AUM ative chapter in a book about the
fraud negligence and use of money to
exploit the scientific ignorance of the
public and leaders to manipulate
policies in our Modern
Age I'm embarrassed that our state's
science committee majority members have
let themselves be tricked by polluter
industry PR in this way this bill is an
affront to all the citizens of New
Hampshire who respect the scientific
consensus about agw and who are
understandably worried about what global
warming from fossil fuel pollution means
for them and their
children public sentiment is
clear influence is
clear New Hampshire is not even a fossil
fuel producing state we have much to
gain from the global transition from a
fossil fuel powered world to an clean
energy powered world we have the
manufacturing the technology the
educated Workforce that can produce the
Clean Energy Solutions we're never going
to PO we're never going to produce the
polluting fossil fuel
Solutions so why are some New Hampshire
leaders participating in the bad actor
part of the fossil fuel industry's
two-phased game they've been tricked by
the C Network's promoted ideology of
free market
fundamentalism an extremist Viewpoint
that the government should stay out of
markets no regulations should be imposed
to protect human health or the
environment the market will act
responsibly all by itself unguided by
policy but economists understand that is
wrong when pollution is free we get too
much of it it is the role of government
to set the rules that protect people the
biodiversity and ecological Services we
all depend on and our property from
being harmed by someone else's economic
activity to address the cases of the
tragedy to address this case of the
tragedy of the
hcr1 is a human-caused climate change
deniers bill as indicated by the whereas
Clauses the granite geek wrote this
about it a New Hampshire Bill pretends
climate change doesn't exist because it
is too scary to face but the premise of
the title of this bill that it would be
a good idea to consider all the costs of
pollution from fossil fuels and state
decisions is a good one let's turn it
around explain the wording is extremist
and alienating anti-science and talk
about external costs and the need to
accept the scientific consensus about
global warming from fossil fuel
pollution as identified in the 2022 New
Hampshire climate assessment report and
the United States Global change research
program's fifth National Climate
assessment we need science-based policy
not ideology-driven
irresponsibility the text should note
the high costs of climate pollution to
New Hampshire citizens damages to New
Hampshire resources and property and
adverse effects on health and
nature if you are tempted to vote out to
pass in this resolution I request the
committee chairman invite our state
climatologist in for a Q&A to clear up
this committee's confusion about agw
that you ask the science technology and
energy committee members on this bill if
they can cite major reports from
scientific organizations rather than
Media or front group's talking points in
support of the claims made in the
resolution why name climate alarmists
rather than note that 30% of New
Hampshire citizens are alarmed like I am
about climate change from fossil fuel
pollution please consider my amended
proposal to this resolution to align
this hcr1 with what we know through
science and with the overwhelming public
sentiment about this very flawed Bill
and from where information about the
two- faced game some leaders in our
state are being tricked by that result
in bills such as hcr1 please see not.org
thank you thank you I have two questions
I'll ask at the same time number one how
do you heat your house number two what
type of vehicle do you drive sure um so
can I take a meta view about these
questions first um carbon shaming is a
tactic that these front groups liked us
to have in our discussion um it's a
personal attack that makes somebody go
on the defensive um but I'll answer the
question I'm not intending to put you on
the defensive simple question of how do
you heat your house what kind of vehicle
do you drive just I'm answer that
now um I heat my house um my I had an
oil burning F furnace it was 40 years
old it started leaking in April it quit
uh I went for 6 months without a furnace
in my house and we started getting
nervous that process I went to the New
Hampshire saves website to see what I
could do about Energy Efficiency and I
got great help from the state uh I
invested some of my own money I'm $9,000
more energy efficient in my house mostly
thanks to the state uh subsidy for that
um but it still wasn't enough uh for the
available heat pump technology to heat
my house they do have these Technologies
in Europe but because of rules in the US
we can't get them here I have forced hot
water with small radiators I need hot
water to push through those radiators to
warm my house sufficiently so I was
forced to buy an oil burning furnace
again much to my dismay um because not
because I'm worried about my own climate
footprint but because I resent having to
pay the fossil fuel industry for its
products when I know that it has spent
decades dragging our
society's legislation from being able to
transition off of fossil fuels to clean
energy it's happening in other countries
and it's not because they're more
Innovative and smarter than we are the
fossil fuel industry has its thumb on
our legislation and delaying that my car
died last year it's been an expensive
couple years for the guge
household luckily electric vehicles in
the US have progressed much faster than
heating systems um heating systems are
great if you have an air system get a
heat pump that's the way to go if you
have a forced hot water system wait two
more years U Mitsubishi is coming out
with a high temperature heat pump system
and that was is probably going to be
great I was just two years too early my
electric vehicle I bought it green wve
EV I test drove a whole bunch of
different kinds right in their parking
lot great place to go for cars um and I
bought a used Kia ev6 it didn't it
didn't um get any of the federal funding
because it was made in Korea not in the
US but I saved $118,000 buying a used
vehicle with low mileage and I
absolutely love it I drove it here uh I
came from Maine yesterday I plugged it
in last night when I got home it was
plenty charge to come here and go back
uh home after this meeting so individual
efforts you know do what you can you
often save money and you do feel better
not giving your money to out ofate
polluting companies but what we need is
federal and State legislation to address
the market failure and I passed out an
economist statement that explains why
nearly every Economist from across the
political Spectrum says a fully rebated
border adjusted cash back carbon fee on
fossil fuels is our best first step to
get a handle on this pollution problem
thank you have any further
questions uh representative Belta saw
you first thank you Mr chairman and
thank you for your testimony you were
very uh clear that you you believe we
should shift away from the polluting
industries of fossil fuels I don't think
I heard you say exactly what you would
if you were in our position what you
would see us replace those energy
sources with so could you just elaborate
on specifically what you would bring in
instead of those yeah sure efficient
market
forces um there's a economists climate
and policy modeling tool from MIT
called nroads n-
roads.org is the website you can run it
from it's got policy sliders that show
if applied globally what policies will
do for Global Sources of primary energy
the resulting greenhouse gas emissions
over this century and the resulting
temperature based on ipcc
modeling now you can try your government
inter you know there's different ways
there's regulations subsidies and
there's putting a price on pollution um
The Economist statement is clear the
most cost effective and Equitable way to
reduce climate pollution is through a
carbon price where the money is rebated
back to households this sends a
pollution price signal through the whole
economy so investors producers and
consumers are all motivated to pollute
less investment in Innovation happens we
get better heat pumps better EV
we get fewer long-term investments in
gas pipelines and more offshore wind um
other countries are doing this Canada is
using carbon fee in dividend the EU is
using a cap in trade but their carbon
price is quite high and growing now the
third part of the magical Economist
solution is the Border adjustment and
that's what the EU is about to do to us
starting next year and this is when your
carbon price gets high enough you charge
your carbon price at the border for the
embedded emissions from free polluting
countries a carbon import tariff we're
going to start paying that to the EU
next year because there's a us a growing
us carbon price Gap so should we pick
EVS or hydrogen cars or windmills or
nuclear you don't need to make that
decision if you have an efficient energy
Market where the costs the true costs of
the you of the production and the use of
the goods are reflected in the price of
the goods this is just a market-based
revenue neutral way to reduce pollution
you don't have to know what the right
Solutions are if you set up the rules in
the economy so that producers and
consumers are doing the best thing both
for themselves and uh for us as a whole
thank you further questions
representative Manion thank you Mr chair
thanks for taking my question so you're
mentioning about the the child uh
anxiety with the climate change and like
even as I was growing up we were told uh
the world's going to end in 10 years and
like as we've seen as even as I've grown
up over 10 years how do you address like
the the failed predictions decade after
decade that the ocean levels are going
to rise that we're going to run away
greenhouse and become Venus that uh the
Midwest is going to become a dust bowl
how how do you uh reconcile that with
the reality thank you that's a great
question and it lets me talk about the
difference between the media and the
science if you've heard the world's
going to end in 10 years think about
where that message came from who's
telling you that somebody said that and
why the ipcc report from which the media
picked up that message said we have 10
more years at the current rate of
emissions to reach the point where the
world will warm up to one and a half deg
that's what the science said now the
media took it in lots of different ways
but don't get your science from your
media go to the report and read it it
came from the special report of global
warming on one and a half degrees
there's a graph in there I teach climate
I teach a class called Help solve
climate change to MIT at MIT to high
school students and one of the graphs I
show is the is from that report
showing there's a carbon budget
remaining to hold warming to 1.5 the
longer we take to start reducing
in the next 10 years the
more vertical the the drop has to be for
us to not go over that carbon budget the
world is not going to end at
1.5 what that report says is that every
0.1 degre Celsius of warming is more
damage and it it looks at the difference
in global effect of 1.5 and 2 and that
so this is where we start to get
personal because I feel climate anxiety
because I've read the
science um I left my job six years ago
to volunteer fulltime to try to help
create the political will to get bipar
and policies passed at the federal level
to address a pollution problem that I
think is the biggest risk to my
daughter's future it's affecting the
nature that I love I love to Nordic ski
but now I have to drive maybe we have
enough snow for the conquered ski the be
race this weekend maybe not uh 30 years
ago we certainly
did our climate is moving northward 50
ft a
day um every day I wake up if I go
outside I Feel Love of Nature and I feel
sadness for what we're
losing so the the front groups and the
media that twists the story around from
fossil fuel perspectives to delay us
addressing this critical pollution
problem is one of the things
it's bad that we're losing what we're
losing but it's frustrating to me that
we're St still stymy decades after the
industry that knew this was coming read
that handout that I gave you Exxon knew
in the 70s that this was happening go to
the two-faced game web page and you'll
see report after report videos from BP
and shell from decades ago warning about
what their pollution was doing to our
future
and we are losing this now and the 1.5
Target is the best we could have done
several years ago now James Hansen in
his newsletter says it's probably too
late maybe even too late for two degrees
they don't know
exactly there's airs in science but
scientific consensus in science is not a
political consensus of everybody just
coming to a
compromise it is a strong understanding
of what we know based on all the
evidence and 's no reasonable
explanation other than the current
scientific understanding for this I'm
still losing sleep over it at least now
I'm able to spend all my time
volunteering to help communicate the
problem and solutions and work on
bipartisan approaches a carbon fee and
dividend is a market-based revenue
neutral approach that will use Mar
efficient market forces to reduce
pollution in a way that protects
household budgets makes us businesses
more competitive in the global
Marketplace and holds heavy polluting
countries accountable for their
pollution and motivates them to price
carbon too thank you thank you forther
questions one follow up thank you uh
just for the follow-up I just want to
clarify so you were saying
um that the media may be exaggerating
the the results of these reports do you
ever count try to fight back against the
media uh exaggerations and tell them
that they're wrong so that kids aren't
killing themselves because they think
the world's going to
end well the thing about the media is
it's funded by billions
right uh I have a voice but I don't have
a billion dollars and so it's not a fair
fight uh you have a lot of people
volunteering their
time protesting coal plants doing person
putting themselves at risk you have
federal and state laws coming in to make
those protests um have heavier penalties
because the polluting industry has more
power than the people um I don't have
any control over the media that people
intake I don't have control over how our
education system works um what I wish
was Public Funding for Education went to
public education that was held
accountable uh for the education that is
being provided um we have all kinds of
problems through this state that are
directed from the Cook network Charles
Koch wants to get rid of public
education he wants to get rid of the EPA
he wants to get rid of a whole bunch of
things that we have put in place to
educate ourselves to protect ourselves
against billionaires who can manipulate
media and get a whole bunch of people to
follow along because that's what they
get from all the different angles okay
Mr Gage Mr Gage I think you have gone
around the mountain long enough here
you've said repeated repeated we've
one so I don't think I won't accept any
more questions
I really appreciate all the time you
gave me T we did give you quite a bit of
time you did thank you very much thank
you
committee next up uh representative
Julius
sodi you've asked for you've asked for
three to five minutes
good afternoon committee members my name
is uh Julius soti I represent wiam and
London I am here to uh um in support the
bill
um could you bring the mic closer to
your M sorry thank you yeah I I support
this bill because
um the state of science is in a
crisis uh um I come at this from a
position of well my degree is in
philosophy and particularly the
philosophy of science theory of
knowledge and
logic all this is is missing from
today's scientific
process it's become sloppy science
motivated by
funding the global warming people want
to shut down the science process and
replace it with
consensus Einstein
there was there was consensus against
him too 100 scientists well it's garbage
and he says you can have a million
scientists like have consensus against
me just one has to prove me
wrong anthropogenic global warming fa
fails the philosophy of science
test they have no coherent Theory or
hypoth hypothesis that makes
reproducible predictions in science if
you can't
make the
prediction you're
wrong they have no mathematical no
definitive mathematical
calculations that can correctly account
for all the variables what they have is
guess work on top of guess work when you
look at how they arrive with some of
their
numbers their assumptions and guesswork
and they Ram it into climate models
would would you would you cross a bridge
that was built that way on
guesswork a true working Theory
should uh work throughout the solar
system and the Universe on all rocky
planets and moons with
atmospheres actually such a theory does
exist a real working Theory the ideal
gas law and there are a couple
scientists Ned ncov and uh Carl Zeller
who mathematically worked it out
predicting the
temperatures of the rocky planets
throughout the throughout our solar
system Venus which has been the analog
for the climate
change
fearmongers
uh there's an exact example of what's
going on here the important part is
atmospheric density and
hot and despite and Mars which also is
over 90% carbon
dioxide is cold but the atmospheric
pressure is very low and it's cold if
you go on Venus is a perfect example
from down at the surface Extreme Hot
pressure and as you move
up the prediction works perfectly when
you reach the air pressure that's on
about 50 kmet up in their
atmosphere the air pressure is is the
same as Earth and so is the temperature
dioxide so the work so that's the
working Theory and this is suppressed by
the other
side other junk SCI that's been seen in
the media
Mythbusters they had a sealed chamber
test with ice in it and then they had a
heat source and they one was the control
the other one was them pumping in carbon
dioxide and they got about a after a
couple hours they got about a degree
difference but they didn't tell you that
they pumped it up to about 70,000 parts
per
million versus the 400 parts that we had
on the planet now and they also didn't
account for the
pressure so that's tell that's telling
science uh I'll finish up with a quote
of what's going on here from uh the
President Eisenhower's address when he
uh left office he warned about the
military industrial complex but he also
warned about the scientific ific
technological
Elite the prospect of domination of a
nation's
Scholars by federal employment project
allocation and the power of money is
ever present and is Gravely to be
regarded yet in holding scientific
discovery in respect as we should we
must also be alert to the equal and
opposite danger that public policy
could itself become a captive of a
scientific
familiar so
ultimately the ultimate Corruption of
science would be the codification of
carbon dioxide into our tax system once
it becomes a revenue
stream game over science is dead you'll
never find out the truth I'll take
questions thank you for that uh
representative
gagy thank you Mr Vice chairman thank
you uh representative sodi for taking my
question um would you say my opinion I
don't know if it's going to be your
opinion that climate change is a reality
and
cyclical yes I I would it's a what's
happening now is not out of the ordinary
there's always been there's been the
medieval warm period and there's the ice
the mini ice age that we had bankovich
cycle so forth there's nothing here
that's out of the ordinary and then you
cannot tease
out 100 particles of carbon dioxide and
say that's why we have climate change
it's an absurdity the real numbers are
predicted by the ideal gas law
throughout the solar system follow up
thank
you okay I'm not a scientists I've got
about 30 college credits I was raised on
the main streets of
Manchester so the these are simple
questions because I'm a simple
man but I do read and if I'm not
mistaken and maybe someone here who's a
history expert would say that in the
1600s I believe that Europe had no
summer because it was cold you can't
blame that on anthrop
anthropo human messing up yeah and would
you also believe followup sir follow up
thank you would you also believe that if
I remember right some time ago decades
several decades ago that there was core
samples taken from about a th000 foot uh
uh core sample that had uh tropical
vegetation in it from Antarctica oh
absolutely there's been and well carbon
dioxide historically has never been a
climate driver it's always been a
climate
lagger it's been a 4,000 9,000 parts per
million the the the climate driver is
atmospheric pressure and density case
closed and and of course the solar
input further
questions go ahead thank you Mr chair
thank you Mr representative so we know
that fossil fuel price prices are tied
directly to Energy prices because we
don't you know on the macro are not able
right now to produce renewable energy
without fossil fuel so we know that to
fact yeah so okay and we also know that
in this part of the country we get less
than 6 hours of daylight for several
months a year and we also know that the
majority of our population is heated by
either electric natural I mean I'm sorry
yes electric natural gas oil or even
wood pellet now which also create carbon
right um I'm holding a piece that says
that we should increase the carbon
tax continually until we hit a certain
point in time we're also in the fourth
most expensive place in the United
States to live in the middle of a
housing crisis what is your prediction
as to what would happen to the New
Hampshire economy and people if we
exercised these uh and implemented these
things without putting up guard rails to
protect New Hampshire people will freeze
and die
thank you further
questions would just like to ask a
question does um do you think that we
are currently over
legislating um in any way um anything
that you know I'd say climate alarmist
would find favorable I mean I guess
that's what a lot of this is about is
trying to rein in that side of that do
you think that that is currently
happening in any way shape or form do I
think what they were over legislating on
the climate well if if we if we codify
this into our tax system um you just
created a revenue stream yeah that's
over
legislating it's creating a bad
incentive you're going to be um why why
would people want to undo that if that's
their revenue
stream that follow up yeah follow up I'm
I'm just wondering I mean obviously
we're we're
not I guess um a part of my question is
do you think you know it was brought up
that we are currently you know jumping
to legislation that we shouldn't be
doing but you know do you agree with
that I mean
obviously we haven't put that much in
place with that said you know well one
of the things about this bill is it says
all s side should be heard and that's
the way the science process is supposed
to work that's fine and I think that
we're fine at that at that
position I don't think we need to do any
kind of
Le forther question oh follow up go
ahead follow I guess um so from your
from your response though I mean do you
even see this as being needed I mean it
we're sitting here right now and we are
listening to both sides well if we're if
we're fearmongering our everybody um
perhaps we should stop Fear mongering
everybody because well everybody knows
fear
sells uh and fear builds upon
itself um perhaps so we could like tap
that
down representative MCH thank you Mr
chairman thank you for being here for
your testimony I just actually wanted to
follow up on that same line of thought
which is what presently exists that
would necessitate this bill so I I want
to ask you because you seem to be aware
of a lot of the these kind of things
that are going
on outside of private ownership which is
a whole different story are you aware of
any large scale um development of solar
or wind that is not subsidized with
taxpayer
money uh no I don't
uh well actually every probably most of
it is all uh subsidized by the
government in one way or shape or
another
thank you further question yes Benn
representative
Bennett sorry I
gu and thank you for taking my question
um to follow up on representative bel's
Point are you aware that over time that
the oil industry the fossil fuel
industry has been hugely subsidized by
our tax tax dollars oh I don't agree
with subsidizing them either thank
Bennett I had several questions but um I
one question I was going to ask is why
are you supporting this bill in
succinctly I think you kind of answered
that but I wanted you to reiterate your
answer because science is a process not
a
consensus you either you're either right
and you're making predictions correctly
or you're wrong you need to get the back
to the drawing board that's what science
is followup followup I just wanted to
say that what we've done here proves to
me that we do need this because we see
that there are two sides and we do need
testimony representative Bachi
thank you sir for uh taking my question
well we've been hearing a lot of you
know things like we need to hear from
both sides so one side is obviously
scientific side what is the other side
specifically could you specify those
other sides well you mean scientists
there are scientists here and then there
are scientists that are being
suppressed that's the other side so
follow up Sir follow up so when
somebody's scientist I would I I would
take them together scientific side or
group and I'm trying to find out the
other side maybe uh uh someone who uh
deny uh you know climate change or
someone else nobody denies climate
change climate change is that's
normal the rate right now the debate is
what the rate that is changing is this
few hundred
molecules of carbon dioxide making a
difference or not to tease that out is
impossibility oh it really it is when
when when you how you're getting
measurements from temperatures from all
over the country and the rest of the
world but the rest of the world doesn't
have nearly the amount of of data it's
it's bunch of
guesswork and and assumptions that's
that's what they into the climate
models if you you cannot predict
anything on a basic basis of all this
guess work a
followup you have a followup um just
brief what's your background are you
have you I studied philosophy philosophy
of science logic and the theory of
knowledge theory of knowledge deals with
how do you know that you know and I am
imminently qualified to examine the
you represent gagy as a final question
there a final question thank you Mr
chairman in your
opinion this bill would this
house concurrent resolution would help
get both sides together in a neutral
setting so they could hash it out
amongst themselves and come up with some
good um resolution that would be
amendable to all to whether clim the the
the heating up of the planet is is is
detrimental or bad or is it cyclical or
just a normal event but they would come
to a conclusion both sides I would hope
spot on if everybody's listened to I
would hope that would be the result
thank you any further
questions go
ahead I'm curious uh we had two bills
before us
yesterday uh for study committees one on
the uh effect of the carbon based and
another one on the economic impact of
failed we were trying to get the
information and get the studies and I'm
curious as to how you voted and why if
you feel comfortable doing so I know you
don't have but why if you don't feel so
then why do you think so many people
well it's perhaps a a step too far and
the way the thing was worded was that we
definitely know there's a problem and we
absolutely have to do something and
we're going to have to light it all up
and this bill is more reasonable it
says let's talk about it figure it out
hash out the numbers look at what's
actually predictable what's not
predictable
and there are range there's a range
there's a there's a range of certainty
to science the more variables you put
in the more chaos you have and the more
unpredictable your
results and and climate science is more
analogous to
economics if if e if economists could
predict things they'd all be rich yeah
it's it's there's too much noise too
much chaos going on for them to be able
do that they could talk they could do
it's a more of a descriptive science
than a predictive science and the
mathematical calculation that I talked
about the ideal gas law that is a
descriptive way to understand the
planets and their
temperatures but what they're going what
they're what they're trying to do is the
climate alarm is s like wa well we're we
know we're going to be on fire I don't
think so thank you any further questions
seeing none thank you very much for your
testim ony now going to call on Dr
Daniel hman he is opposed to the bill
minutes thank you um for taking my
testimony good afternoon excuse me I'm a
retired um physician um with a specialty
in um
Psychiatry um I want to talk about my
impression of this bill which is that
it's a bill with false equivalence
climate science is an ongoing scientific
process with researchers working
worldwide scientists obtained their
positions after years of studies of
subjects such as math statistics
chemistry physics oceanography biology
atmospheric science geology and computer
modeling I looked up the requirements
for climate science it is published in
peer-reviewed journals with data
collected from satellites groundbased
measurements and GE ologic records the
analysis and conclusions are o openly
available and are open as is the
scientific process to criticism
reproducibility and ongoing
modifications if the data warrants I'd
also like to add that in my career and
in my life I've known many scientists of
all different stripes the vast majority
of them are dedicated people who are
underpaid relative to what their skills
could command and in the private sector
and they're really dedicated to science
that's not to say they aren't bad actors
and I've known some of them but the vast
majority of of scientists are are true
and honest people that are doing their
best according to the American
Association for the advancement of of
science there is a clear consensus that
word has been bandied about and
scientists do come up with consensus 90
you've heard the term
97% it it varies depending on the sample
size some have gone as high as 100% but
these are of published climate
scientists and they're in agreement that
humans are causing global warming and
climate change I should add if I
remember my college chemistry that Bo's
law does has nothing to do with
greenhouse gases and and how uh carbon
dioxide absorbs radiation and radiates
it back um to the Earth the effects are
at present a 1.4 degree rise in
temperature over the last 100 years a
rise in sea level heat waves and periods
of heavy precipitation thousands of
people have died worldwide from climate
change Millions have had their lives
disrupted and the costs are in the
billions environments are being
permanently damaged and
biodiversity which is a critical piece
of this because the environment
interacts with the climate is being
disrupted and declining
we are at risk of pushing our climate
toward abrupt unpredictable irreversible
damaging changes the sooner sooner we
act we lower the risk and costs the
problem with carbon dioxide is when it
accumulates it lasts for decades and
centuries we can't just turn it's like
turning a a cruise liner you turn the
knob down now it doesn't start to go for
a long time so that's the sense of
urgency you know everyone's talking
about alarmism the problem is
not um alarmism so much as recognizing
the problem that if we don't cut it down
now we're getting even further behind
the
curve um we're we're the more we produce
we're passing risks down to our future
to Future Generations which is a
terrible Legacy but that's what keeps me
up at night I'm
70 you know I'm G to make it through I'm
worried about my kids my grandkids
that's why I'm here
today um the other piece of this which
seems to get lost is the adoption of
green
energy um many e many including 28 Noel
winning economists feel that it will
improve our economy our health and
environment the only losers really are
the fossil fuel industry and that's the
reality the CL the problem with the
other side is it's not science the
spectrum of of opinion that was referred
to in this bill is between science-based
knowledge and disinformation that's been
published by oil billionaires and their
fossil fuel companies and that's the
false
equivalence thank you thank you for your
testimony do I have any
questions representative belgum thank
you Mr chairman thank you for being here
for your testimony I just wanted to
nailed down one point I believe you said
that most of the scientists that you've
known um they are underpaid and they
could make more they could command a
higher salary in the public sector I
just wanted to drill down are is it your
testimony that the majority of
scientists that you know then are
dependent on Government funding for
their
income well if you talk about university
positions or um funded positions yes
um I don't know where all they're fund I
mean some of it comes from private uh
organizations there are a lot of
different revenue streams that uh I
should say that I don't I I'm not sure
whether I would answer that with yes but
a lot of um funding does come from the
government I'm
sure thank you other
questions
see sorry representative Bennett um I
guess I'm kind of curious as to the same
kind of question like why are you
opposing this bill to me this bill looks
like we're going to talk about things
and so why are you opposing it yeah
that's a good question the it just seems
like it's more of the same it's a way to
keep up the The Fog of disinformation by
saying yes there are two sides to it
which is really there's a a science side
and there's a non-science
side this is not a debate you know if
you have facts you have facts um if
those facts can be um drilled down we
can look at it more closely but to talk
about it as though humans are not
producing climate change you know over
the last I don't know 100 years but it's
gone up 1.4 the amount of carbon dioxide
in the air has gone up from 200 Parts um
to 400 the last time we had this was 15
million years
higher thank you any further questions
seeing none thank thank you for your
testimony thank you
appreciate and now we're down to two
tickets left I
got won
Sinkler he is opposed to the
bill he's asked for two
minutes thank you Mr chairman I'm
Wharton Sinkler from uh Sandwich New
Hampshire and I'm opposed to the bill uh
for a couple of reasons one I want to
read the um the main resolution part
itself calling on policy makers locally
and nationally to fully consider all
relevant information and factors
pertaining to climate change before
pursuing courses of action that could
adversely affect any economy or
environment to me this goes without
saying so I'm kind of wonder ing why we
need a resolution in fact really any
policy or legislation that that our
legislature considers should uh fully
consider all relevant information before
uh vote so to me it just seems silly to
do something that already is uh is is
really goes without saying and should be
understood um and and is not even
specific to climate change and then the
other part of the resolution involves a
lot of assertions in the uh whereas
section and I'll read a couple of these
whereas there is a documented pattern of
suppression of some climate perspectives
and
data uh wrong many historically wrong
climate predictions a long history of
climate alarmism and intimidation by
special interests implying uh corruption
essentially special interests putting
pressure on science you know I think the
question here is where is where is the
border where is the boundary of these
statements you know I mean we have we
have a a state
climatologist um Professor Mary stampone
of uh UNH and you know she wrote a
climate assessment uh in 2021 or
co-authored it you know it makes an
assertion that uh based on measurements
of temperature the temperature has
increased throughout the 20th century in
the state of New Hampshire and has
accelerated since about
1970 uh right up to 2020 is that a is
that a a statement that we should be
suspicious of as corrupt
or uh or cherry-picking uh and
suppression of other opinions
or or another
example you know if you go on the NASA
website today it says Greenland ice
sheet is losing ice it's losing ice to
the tune of two about 270 billion metric
tons a year that's a lot of ice okay and
there are careful measurements being
done to get get us that number is that
number now based on the these whereas
statements it seems seems like that
number should be doubted you know and my
so my question is you know is is there
of course we've heard some crackpot
assertions made by you know climate
alarmists too right they're they're out
there I have absolutely no uh doubt and
no I don't dispute that at all but when
you paint with such a broad brush in
these assertions you're really not doing
anybody a favor because you're not being
clear enough about what is what
represents good science and what doesn't
we have a very proud tradition in this
country of scientific inquiry that has
brought a huge progress going all the
way back to the founding fathers through
the the founding of the National Science
Foundation by uh Abraham Lincoln
President Abraham Lincoln um these are
proud things and we should be careful
not to throw out great science just
because of a you know of a of kind of
poorly formulated assertions that are
then voted on by the New Hampshire
legislature and approved why would you
approve these statements they need to be
elaborated on there's more there's more
going on I'm a scientist I've worked in
science my whole life I actually worked
in the private sector uh for the fossil
fuel industry okay and I know yeah and I
know a lot of scientists and not all of
them have integrity but I can also say
that many many many of the people that I
admire most in the world are scientists
and I admire them most of all because
they the minute they sniff a
problem in the in the data that
something doesn't something do isn't
right that they they will they will uh
distance themselves from that so fast
it'll make your head spin that's
Integrity in science and it's it's out
there it's real it's good we should
applaud it and yeah I I I think this uh
is a poorly worded resolution in my
opinion it has makes assertions that
that are unfair and I hope you will uh
judge it in expedient to legislate thank
questions seeing none I thank you for
your testimony and we have one card left
left it is George
scker
SAR h s RC SC I'm not good at
pronouncing weird words or is it
Jose no the Joe
is he lives two King
Road two King Road that's me all right
could you straighten me out of my
pronunciation and am and I totally
apologize don't you worry about it it's
old Lithuanian name and it's difficult
you he
is testimony and he's asked for five
minutes and this is the last card
esteemed chairman Mett chairman Rollins
dear members of the committee my name is
yur matot which is difficult to
pronounce I'm representing myself I'm a
German citizen retired in September 202
three from my professorship in Germany
and currently work at Dartmouth College
I'm neutral on this proposal and as far
as its wording goes you are a lot more
experienced than I will ever be on this
issue my experience is on environmental
and climate science having served as a
full professor and chair I volunteered
as advisor on climate change related
issues to the sexon government in
Germany as of the year 2000 I co-chaired
a biannual conference on Regional
climate change targeting decision makers
and stakeholders as an honest broker
translating science to a more generalist
audience as a longtime member of the
German ipcc team in the working group
one for the physics of climate change
which works like a think tank I reviewed
IP ipcc tasks and identified knowledge
gaps I am concerned about human activity
driven climate change because it poses
significant and avoidable risks to
societies including us in New England it
does not help to turn a blind eye to
this hoping that these risks move away
by
themselves however related challenges
can be met by preparing for the known
and highly likely as well as by critical
scrutiny of the evidence in all related
fields of
expertise I'm also concerned about
misperceptions in the public
understanding of the issue which Drive
irrational behavior and inappropriate
reactions rather than supporting calm
scrutiny and open
discussion the bill proposes to improve
the legislative process by considering
all relevant information pertaining to
climate change let me provide an examp
example of relevant information that is
often missing from current climate
discussions the likely biggest
misperception is that climate change
questions planetary survival we need to
save the
world that is uncalled for and of little
to no help instead we need to look at
opportunities and possibilities that can
help us counter climate change to adapt
to irrevocable consequences as well as
to benefit from local and Regional
chances that automatically emerge from
climate
Dynamics my personal experience with
climate information or alarmism includes
the following story as an academic
teacher I'm in close contact with a
young generation and perceive their
worries as responsible citizen with
expert background in climate change
related matters I volunteered in serving
a regional government as Regional
government adviser in Germany and never
turned down requests by public services
schools community colleges or
universities to discuss the topic with
lay people it is in this context that I
quickly learn two things one that normal
people like every one of us can neither
automatically understand the scientific
jargon
nor the displays of science graphics and
two that many people often feel helpless
and intimidated by much of the public
discussion in media and even public
hearings this Insight changed my way of
communication with lay people and led to
products such as a free booklet entitled
climate change climate Swindle targeting
a l
audience the a ancient Greek politician
and general Pericles said quote it is
not about predicting the future but of
being prepared for it it is this
foresighted and constructive spirit that
any society needs to face future the
future and its challenges to
successfully develop and open
opportunities for future
Generations my personal bottom line is
very simple there is no reason to panic
panicking never solves problems but
usually leads to Agony or inappropriate
reactions there is reason however to
take precautions and to increase
societal
resilience this can be done following no
regret principles which means that
measures taken neither waste resources
nor do damage even if the future reality
does not turn out EX exctly as projected
today thank you very much for the
opportunity to talk to you this is a
extreme honor and of course I'm
available to questions thank you any
questions representative hennyway thank
you Mr chair thank you Professor for
coming and for your work that you're'
doing um so you talked about the future
and the planning and how we go about
making oursel more resilient uh what do
you see our plan should be
to do this do we go uh nuclear uh solar
uh uh wind power do you have another
another source of energy that you wouldd
like to throw out we we could probably
spend weeks now but let me use my New
Hampshire
experience uh I have seen the torrential
rains last
summer I have seen drought last year no
not last summer second last summer
excuse me in vermond in New Hampshire in
particular extreme weather events are
increasingly becoming likely to highly
likely in our
region they do damage that we know and
partly can assess quick pretty precisely
so a precautionary principle means that
we strengthen infrastructure wherever
it's needed in order to avoid major
hassle by destroyed Bridges and and and
and and and
and when it comes to energy Supply
because you address that
too I tell you a little story from Japan
because I have been working for quite a
while in
Japan Japan has a gigantic potential for
geothermal energy because it's active
rich in active
volcanism yes they do have a few less
than
20 very very efficient geothermal power
plants which is a tiny fraction of the
potential why do they not use it I can't
tell you the entire story but there is
certain interests against it and the
funniest thing is the onen industry onen
are hot bath that you submerge to to
relax because you wash yourself
beforehand and this is pretty important
industry because it's part of the
culture the funny thing is the truth or
the reality the physical reality behind
it is that the abstraction of geothermal
energy from these
volcanoes does not do any damage to anen
activity because there's such a gigantic
surplus of energy and still the argument
of the lobbyism for onance overpowers
the societal
discussion I think I answered your
question
indirectly thank you representative
gagy thank you Mr chair thank you
welman uh that's about the only German
word I know
dun thank you very much
it you were talking about Japan isn't
that a similar uh scenario in Iceland
where they're sitting on top of a
Caldera pretty much you are right it is
similar in respect to the geothermal
potential but unlike Japan the Icelandic
thank you any further questions
representative Bel thank you Mr chairman
and thank you for being here for your
testimony I wanted to drill just a
little bit into the statement you made
regarding the the severe rain and
weather events that we've had because
certainly being you know representing
part of a mountainous region we had some
serious flooding going on but I'm I'm
trying to wonder from your perspective
as a as somebody who's has a background
in climate science and with and with
these organizations how do we how can
you differentiate between something that
was hum driven and that therefore we can
continue we can expect will continue in
the long term versus and I don't know
how widespread this knowledge is the
hung a Tong of volcano eruption that
occurred underwater a couple years ago
that was such a massive volcanic
eruption underwater that it increased
atmospheric water concentration by about
10% immediately leading a lot of people
to say we're going to have a wet and hot
de
so how do we differentiate between those
things this is a very good
question and um that is something why we
in climate science need numerical
Dynamic
models now it would probably take me
quite a while to explain these models
and the thermodynamic and the fluid
Dynamic functions behind it the idea is
that you make a computer Dynamic
computer model that contains the
important processes that we know from
the planetary functioning including of
course volcanism including the radiation
balance from the Sun
including anything we
can and then we run these computer
models on very powerful machines in
order to have very many different runs
parallel runs where we change the
initial conditions and this allows us to
mathematically differentiate what is
doing what is triggering what with what
kind of likeliness this is why you find
and likeliness means statistics yeah
extremely likely is something like 99%
certain statistically certain highly
likely is like 95% statistically certain
and so on and so forth and this way you
differentiate between the different
let's say triggers of an effect and then
you do go to these places usually with
geophysical instruments or whatever you
have and try to verify or falsify this
computer output and this is how it works
in a in a tiny tiny nutshell does that
satisfy your question okay thank you
further
questions I have one um cloud seating do
you what can you tell us your opinion is
on the cloud seating I know that they're
putting chemicals into the atmosphere to
help cut down on the UV rays but can you
give me your opinion of how this may be
climate that's a neat question I mean
Society Human Society has played with
cloud seeding basically as of the Advent
of
aircraft if I'm not mistaken the
Russians were the first to use it and it
has been used and developed ever
since um if you understand the physics
of cloud formation and we talking about
the clouds in the in the near atmosphere
in the lower troposphere because the
other ones are Irrelevant for the
precipitation so something which is
roughly between what is it a mile and a
mile and a half above our heads we can
send aircraft there cheaply and Seed it
usually with silver chloride and the
silver chloride particles they're tiny
tiny tiny so they act as attractors for
humidity and they form form little water
droplets and they rise up and down and
what is to become a growing cloud and
once it has reached a certain density
and weight it'll fall off out of the
cloud and we call it rain the problem is
we can't do that in a way that is truly
meaningful for what it is meant for to
get precipitation where you want
precipitation that's one thing the other
thing is that and that is much more
related to the very big picture of
climate
change Cloud Dynamics is currently
changing all over the world and we don't
fully understand this again I would need
a lot more time to go into more detail
with you but the key point is that the
chemistry of the atmosphere sorry the
chemistry of the atmosphere which
differs from the Earth's surface to the
tropopause first and then further on
into the stratosphere and then even
beyond that
is changing with climate change so
there's different temperatures and
there's different pressure
regimes maybe you have heard of rosby
waves no um don't worry it is something
that defines how much arctic cold we get
in the winter and partly also in the
summer and these rosby waves they are
basically like a roller coaster going on
the Northern Hemisphere at about 10,000
no what is it in feet 7,000 ft above our
heads and they are slowing down we have
ideas why they are slowing down but we
don't know for sure it's a pretty recent
phenomenon but what it does is it
changes cloud formation and that reaches
down well to Florida on the Northern
Hemisphere and the same happens on the
southern hemisphere in a mirror image
like form so there's many open questions
to that respect Cloud physics is about
the most complicated one right now okay
thank you any other questions seeing
none I'm going to call a close to
hcr1 you and uh the blue team will cck
us in one room we're going to cck us in
the side room over here and we'll all be
minutes
e
okay folks about a two-minute warning
and uh we will begin our executive
session we're going to try to get
through the seven remaining measures
that this committee
has and I want to thank while she's
working hard our uh interim clerk don't
take me
yet um represent man bomb could not be
here
today representative Lloyd has stepped
up
and if if it works out there could be a
meritorious service medal no no no
guarantees I shouldn't say that
early Good Conduct for sure so another
another minute or so and we'll uh we'll
start with HB
264 uh that has to do with Article
we'll be ready in about a minute or
so I'll point out that we have spent uh
time a considerable time on all seven of
these measures for we've let everybody
who wanted to testify to all of
them some of them were longer hearings
than
others we all have run notes we also uh
do check the online testimony I was just
on there uh last night and this morning
myself actually and appreciate everybody
who does take the time to show up and th
and those who take the time to who can't
show up I know if you live in Bur Orland
and you have a job it's not easy to come
down here to testify for 3 minutes so uh
we take I take I'm sure we all take the
testimony very seriously that people
take the time to submit
online uh in room Madam clerk you're
you're
good I think I'm all set you may have to
guide me through some of the process but
we're good thank you
okay so our first as I just said our
first measure that we're going to have
an executive session discussion and vote
on is HB 264 Article 5 delegates I
understand uh rep Manion you have a
motion pending yes I do Mr chair I move
OTP on hb2 64 as always we need a second
representative beler seconds so we have
a motion of
OTP from representative Manion in a
second from representative Belzer
representative Manion would you care to
speak to your motion I do thank you Mr
chair so uh we've had like a lot of uh
Article 5 Convention of States
applications come through here there are
people who have concerns about things
like runaway uh conventions and things
being proposed that may not be uh uh
what we intended to send our delegates
down there to do so the a bill like this
I think is a real strong um uh you know
play to keep the those people's fears at
Bay and I think it's really solid we
should uh pass it thank you
representative representative
to your second nothing
further other thoughts uh on the OTP
Lane okay um and I agree that I I have
the same concerns about a runaway
convention so I guess I read it and you
have to forgive me I'm a lawyer by
training so when I read roman numeral 2
it says the convention shall not support
or approve the proposing of an
unauthorized Amendment to the US
convention and but it doesn't say and
and I'm assuming if they do anything
then that's when the felony be kicks in
what happens if the
convention overrides I mean that that
delegate doesn't vote the New Hampshire
delegate doesn't vote but everybody else
decides that they're going to go ahead
with the and in create the runaway
convention
scenario what happens to the New
Hampshire delegate at that point do they
participate or if they participate does
the felony be kick in a second
time that and again I think the idea is
good I'm just trying to make sure that
we got the right
wording I might be able to speak thank
you uh rups of Manion I'm looking to
reps of Lan could you I just pulled out
the actual measure the line you
mentioned was line 16 and 17 16 17 okay
and thank you please speak to that if
you could representative
Manion right so uh you were saying that
um if the convention goes ahead and
passes it anyway it says here so the
delegate from the state to an article
shall not support or
approve the proposing so as long as they
they vote against I think they're in the
clear doesn't really matter like as long
as they're not the ones doing it like
supporting or approving
correct but that's the that's the
proposing of it they can't support the
proposing of it but once oh I see what
you mean but once then it gets so I
agree with you on that but then then the
next step is oh oh dear the other 49
states voted and the New Hampshire guy
didn't end so now they go zooming ahead
and I just from the English the sentence
structure like it should to me it could
be interpreted as shall not support or
statements me I I think I can resolve
this if I may uh please resolve this
representative thank you so I I think
the the the question we're looking at
here is is is a question of the
terminology but the idea behind an
article 5
convention the the actual effect of what
they're doing is proposing they can't
adopt they can only prop propos because
it would have to then be voted on by by
States
so shall not support or approve the
proposing proposing is the function that
they're performing so there I don't I
actually don't think that there's a
problem
there representative Lloyd so I guess to
that same point then would that preclude
us from voting
against at
all what I would say to that is that the
should this ever move forward the
delegates who've been selected to
participate in such a convention uh that
the notion that they would go off the
reservation and deviate from their
expressed uh purpose for being there if
you'll look at lines 18 and 19 the last
two lines of the bill uh a delegate who
knowingly violates this section she'll
be guilted of a class B felony and uh
the I think that question was asked
during the testimony though because I
watched it on tape but I don't remember
what the answer was M Mr
chairman yes with regard to class B
felony what that means go ahead
representative uh gagy okay thank you Mr
chairman well first answering to class B
FY felony that's a class B felony is
three and a half to seven years in
prison if convicted that's a clasby
felony but as I read here uh line 16 a
delegate from the state in Article 5 it
can be one delegate let's say we have
four delegates and all
four go against what the state has told
them that the only thing that they can
do then whatever they do would be Moot
and they could all be
charged in my opinion with a class B
felony because they not doing what they
were delegated to bring forth
representative Lloyd um I I agree with
that piece of it um representative gagy
but um I think our biggest concern is
that um a proposal would be made by a
state that is not New Hampshire and
would that limit our delegates from
being able
to um to vote in any way or or affect
how things go my interrup as I read this
is that it seeks to be very clear and
very specific and very limited delegates
from New Hampshire would be uh mandated
to focus on the narrow issue that they
were selected for and if they did
deviate from that they would be uh
subject to a class B felony and again is
uh to reiterate what I think
representative Belzer or Manion said uh
please we need to understand this
convention ition is simply a gathering
to support prospective amendments the
this convention does not make any final
decision or vote on any Amendment all
they do is agree to put certain proposed
amendments in play and then any subject
to you know ratification later on by 38
States so other thoughts on any piece of
this representative gagy
uh getting back to the
Penalty that class be if this um house
house bill 264 would pass the house here
in the Senate and get signed in uh
before that happens if it passes the
house he would have to go I believe to a
second committee like criminal justice I
know when I was in criminal justice we
would get bills from other committees
that they that criminal justice
committee would just deal with with the
the penalty portion of the bill and not
anything else correct and what I want to
avoid doing is I look at this this bill
is very very narrow all it does is with
regard to a potential Article 5
convention is made clear that there
would be a consequence if any delegate
uh
uh uh supporter approved an amendment
not authorized by our legislature so uh
we don't need to get into the the
greater issue of other the merits or
pluses or minuses in Article 5
convention this simply says uh there a
consequence if any selected delegate
deviates from their charge other
thoughts questions comments seeing
seeing none uh Madam interim clerk uh
when you're ready uh the motion is OTP
FN Vice
chair uh thank you uh Vice chair Rollins
yes uh representative Dolan
yes uh representative uh
G no gas g thank you sir G yes
uh representative gagy
yes representative Manion yes
representative beler
yes representative Bennett yes
representative Hemingway yes
representative plant
yes representative
cybert
yes uh representative Judy is not
here uh clerk myself uh I I vote
Yes uh representative Jones
no representative Lane
yes uh representative budak
yes representative
Harnet
no representative jurus yes oh I
accidentally marked this one this one
should be
no okay the which one to clarify
Harnet would yeah please clarify that uh
representative Harnet can you clarify
your vote one more time no thank you and
then do I have you initial or something
to make a change ask me what my vote is
oh Mr chairman what would you like to
vote chair votes
John
15-2 in the affirmative to
OTP so the
OTP uh motion passes
15-2 uh reports uh representative Manion
I'll get with you we'll get together on
a report for that will there be a
minority report representative sabert I
don't think unless one of you guys want
to do it unless do you want to do a
minority on that represent
representative Jones you want to do a
Minority Report thank you no thank you
okay uh by the way these reports as was
the case last week if they could get
Come to Me by 2000 by 800m on Sunday and
uh Rosen cyber if if if a Minority
Report manifests itself somehow
uh just I would just ask that I know
about it and get it by uh 800 p.m on
Sunday I'll put in a one L yeah we'll
see yeah I'll get it over okay uh one
down six to go the next one is uh a
bigger one I I think we could say uh
it's hcr3 which
uh involves applying for a Convention of
the states under Article 5 of The
Constitution of the United States hcr3
Article 5 convention
I am looking again to uh representative
beler uh for a motion thank you Mr
chairman I would move on to pass motion
from representative beler is OTP ought
to pass is there a second second second
from representative Manion uh
representative beler uh would you care
to speak to your motion yes thank you Mr
chair so this motion calls for the
application of an article 5 convention
under specific yet relatively wide
enough terms to look to solve some
problems now I'll offer my own uh non
nonsense assessment here which is
honestly I am a little bit skeptical
that it will be successful in ultimately
reigning in the federal government but
I'm also very skeptical that there's
much danger involved actually the reason
that there's not much danger involved is
the same reason that I'm a little bit
skeptical about the efficacy of it that
said there is an awful lot of decent
people who want the opportunity to try I
see no good reason to deprive them off
that opportunity and I do very much hope
they prove me
wrong thank you representative
representative Manion to Echo uh the to
me it's like the the specifics of this
bill of this specific application are
very good because the the debt is insane
right now it is like one of the largest
security threats to the country right
now the destabilization of the dollar I
think we need to do everything in our
power and that means from the state's
perspective so be we should move forward
with something like this thank you
representative my brief comment is I
have two comments one of which to be
clear there are a lot of folks I hear
saying that an article 5 convention is
unconstitutional so I have to as a
Civics person I have to say that an
article 5 convention would be the least
unconstitutional action I think could be
taken because Article 5 is from the
Constitution it's specifically it's
Article 5 of the United States
Constitution so the notion that it would
be unconstitutional I that my opinion is
I agree with the founders who put it in
the Constitution that it could not be
more constitutional in my humble opinion
uh and the other point I want to make is
that we have spent a lot of time on this
uh those of us who've been on this
committee for several terms uh it passed
this Committee in a bipartisan fashion
last term uh it did not pass the full
floor or the full house but uh I I do
need to point out that this is a measure
that has passed this committee before
last term other thoughts comments
questions uh on any piece of
this is that a hand up Representative
gagy no I'm scratch my you carry on
scratch that ear uh any other comments
on
this seeing none then we have a motion
and we have a second and we will have a
vote Madame uh Madam
clerk I'll repeat the motion and and you
feel free to do as well so that everyone
watching and listening knows what is
happening so the motion is
OTP on hcr3 house concurrent resolution
three resolution three applying for a
Convention of the states under Article 5
of The Constitution of the United
States Vice chairman Rollins yes
yes uh representative Dolan yes
representative G
yes uh representative gagy yes
representative Manion yes representative
Belcher yes representative Bennett yes
representative Hemingway yes
representative plant yes Representative
cybert
no uh representative Judy is not
here uh myself I vote uh yes or
no uh representative Jones
no representative
Lane
no shoot I did this
again representative Jones do you mind
clarifying your vote one more
time no thank you uh Representative
budak no rep representative Harnet no
Representative jurus
no
two one two three four five six seven
eight
n the vote is nine to seven oh oh Mr
chairman I'm so
sorry this I'm not the chair votes yes
thank you uh 10 7 the vote is 107 yes
should be 11
today okay thank you madam clerk uh
majority report uh representative
Belzer
and representative cyber I'm going to
guess it might be a minority Port yeah
and that would be from who should we
look to for that um I'll do it okay uh
cyber thanks thank you to both of you
and again we'll look for that by uh by
Sunday
evening bringing us to hc5
hc5 is a measure house concurrent
resolution that would resend the house
concurrent resolution number 40 which
was passed by the 2012 new General Court
asking that Congress call a convention
under Article 5 of the United States
Constitution so 13 years ago this body
the general court did pass uh what at
the time was ACR number 40 uh asking for
a
convention and this measure SE seeks for
us to resend that measure that is
currently on the record from 2012
so I'm looking for a motion on that uh
I'm going
to
um go ahead uh State your motion I would
like to make a motion for OTP on this do
we have a
second second no oh I think I
representative Buddha Buddha seconds the
motion of OTP on acr5 uh represent cyber
would you care to speak to your OTP
motion yeah I remember um last year this
being the um and I don't think this was
mentioned this time um actually yet but
the original sponsor of this legislation
um actually you know requested that this
be resented and I know being in their
position I would want the I would you
know like it if somebody did the same
for me um if I had second thoughts or
you know you know later down the road
saw any unintended consequences um so
yeah that's just my statement on that so
thank you representative representative
budak you seconded the OTP I 100% agreed
with what cyber
said okay now I'll point out that if any
measure fails uh if an OTP measure fails
we would need an alternate motion which
may or may not happen we'll have to see
what the votes are so other thoughts on
the OTP
motion representative
Belcher thank you Mr chair I having just
voted for a new call for an article 5
convention I I see no reason to resend
and perhaps artificially narrow the the
potential circumstances of a future
Article 5 convention and to the other
issue I would I would simply say with no
disrespect whatsoever to the original
initiating member some years ago once
you've uh filed legislation and that
legislation gets voted on in the house
it's no longer a members legislation
it's house legislation um so there's no
impetus to withdraw uh at that point
Thank you you're saying that someone
shouldn't feel personal ownership of a
of a measure once and that's a point
well taken I think that those of us who
have had measures in the past we need to
uh understand that once we give it to a
committee the committee owns it and then
the house owns it if it moves forward
that's that's a good point repr man did
you have a hand up
uh thank you for that representative
Belcher any other thoughts comments
regarding the motion of OTP
representative Jones thank you uh Mr
chair
um for staying consistent I uh voted
against the other Article Five motions
today but uh with this one I will be
voting yes to stay
consistency
understood other
thoughts seeing No Hands we have a
motion of OTP
on uh that would be uh
H
cr5
and uh just just one moment Madame clerk
if you can get your paperwork
time okay uh proceed when you're ready
all right Vice chairman Rollins
no uh representative Dolan no no
representative gon no representative
Gagney no
madame Duna representative Manion
no representative Belcher no
representative Bennett no representative
Hemingway no representative plant no
representative
cybert yes representative Judy is not
here
representative Lloyd I vote uh
yes representative
Jones I'm a
yes representative Lane
yes representative bataki
yes representative Harnet
yes and representative
jurus yes and Mr
chairman
no two
two
three all right um the motion fails uh
10 to 7 with one
absent thank you madam clerk uh now we
need a an alternate measure or or motion
uh I'd like to make a motion
representative Manion go ahead itl on
hc5 motion of itl on HCR 5 do we have a
second I'll second that is that
representative belcho with the second
thank you uh representative Manion would
you speak to your itl motion please yeah
the inverse of everything we just said
where you're supporting uh Article 5
here and uh we're going to maintain this
application if everyone knows what
inverse means and I'm going to go to
representative
beler thank you Mr chair and Ando the
same sentiments I I would hate to see us
having just voted for an article 5
convention possibly conflict with that
in any way by now resending
this thank you uh representative Bel
that the logic is hard to argue with
least for me other questions thoughts
comments representative Lane I would
just point out that there are some of us
who did vote consistently just not the
in executive session we allow a wide
latitude of
commentary other
comments seeing No Hands uh Madam clerk
when you are ready the uh latest motion
is uh itl on
hr5 Vice chairman Rollins
yes uh representative Dolan yes
representative gon yes representative
Gagney yes
representative Manion yes representative
Belcher yes representative Bennett yes
representative Hemingway yes
cybert um
no representative Judy is
absent uh myself I vote no
no representative Lane no Representative
budak
no Representative hernet no
Representative jurus no and Mr chairman
yes
two itl pass
uh 107 with one non
vote representative Manion was that was
you that made the uh the motion would
you work on the report for US
Representative saber do we have some uh
yourself
okay okay that brings us now to hjr one
house joint resolution one we had a
hearing on that a week ago uh
representative Bela was the sponsor I'm
going to look to him for a motion on the
measure that he was the for which he was
the Prime
sponsor thank you Mr chairman I'll move
a to
pass OTP motion by representative beler
on hjr one ought to pass is there a
second second represent Manion thank you
uh seconding that representative
Bel I'm going to ask you to uh take some
time if you would uh it was a month a
month it was a week ago that we heard
this and I know that not everybody was
completely clear on on it all so if you
if you could uh provide some clarity at
this time that would be representative
CRA is agreeing with me so uh if you
could provide some clarity yes I thank
you Mr Cher I will attempt to do so uh
in retrospect in hindsight I tried to
hit the pragmatic passion portions of
this resolution and limit the depth I
was delving into the more philosophical
aspects the questions seemingly revealed
that there was a much more interest in
those aspects so I'd like to take just
two or three minutes here to run through
that real quick what the point is the
purpose of the bill
so ideas have consequences and the
internal logic of the ideas held by any
society will tend to overtime
see themselves worked out toward their
logical conclusions the framework that
the American government was created
under was a particular set of ideas that
fit together and work together toward a
coherent and cohesive whole the
foundational principles of American
government simply do not work when you
begin to substitute in other alternative
ideas where the founding ideas
were so
let's describe what we're really getting
at here is the concept of
Ethics uh throughout the history of
Western Civilization there have been two
primary different tract for ethics there
has been the trative ethics that comes
from
the primarily from the Greeks the
philosophers Plato Aristotle this line
of thought continued down through
history Through the Ages um right
through uh rouso and Hegel leading up to
the political philosoph some of the
political philosophies of modern
time now these ideas these ethics are
derived really they were laid out well
by Aristotle in his book nikachi and
ethics where he lays the basis for moral
relativism and what that means is He
suggests that the idea the ethical ideal
the good is found in the middle between
two extremes
so you've got two different ideas and
what is good according to Aristotle is
going to be found in the middle of those
two things that's relativistic
ethics this continued throughout history
This Thread this idea of the of
relativistic Ethics through Russo's
concept of the general
will and Russo's Concepts were picked up
later by philosopher Hegel through his
concept the state is the Divine idea
now there is a political system that is
the product of this philosophical threat
of ideas and that political system is
called
democracy
democracy was not a very wellth thought
of concept by the American Founders if
you look at what they had to say about
it particularly in The Federalist Papers
they engineered a government a
government unique in the history of the
world that Blended ele ments from very
many different systems but they sought
specifically to avoid the pitfalls of
democracy that suggest that the general
will or the greatest number of people
necessarily have the right idea about
things because what happens is when you
do that when you assume that the
greatest number of people have the right
idea about things that means that they
can take your rights away with a simple
majority vote that was not the idea that
American government was founded on the
idea that American government was
founded on was the other tract of
thought that has been with us also for a
very long time and that is the
judeo-christian concept of a
Transcendent ethic which is where that
word Transcendent from the resolution
comes from the idea of a Transcendent
ethic means that there is something
above government that government is not
the last and final Arbiter of Truth ex
represent yeah I'd like to call point of
thank you repr saber I I did ask the uh
the the prime sponsor to provide some
clarity which which past two or three
minutes at this point uh so represent
beler if you could just just just to be
clear about a point of order if there is
a if there is a motion to move the
question I'm happy to hear it and we can
take a vote on it otherwise I believe I
have the privilege to speak as a member
Cor correct you've already had the
opportunity as a prime sponsor you know
right well procedurally uh a you can
call the question uh and if you're doing
that then we'll we'll vote on call we
not have a time limit then on this for
like
five I think we're going past the two or
three minutes here well it was me that
asked him to provide some clarity
because uh I I think some of us wanted
to get better Clarity or understanding
of the in
because as I said at the uh initial
hearing I thought the the measure was
somewhat esoteric and so I know we've
been reading it in processing it so uh
represent Bel I'd ask you to if you can
wrap up and we're getting very near the
end of what iend to finish your your
your Clarity Mission please yeah thank
you thank you so as I was saying the
system of government set up by the
founders unique in world history Place
something above government meaning
government doesn't get to take your
rights away rights are there
inalienable and that is what I was
getting at when I talked about the idea
resolution representative second the the
measure do you want to add to that I
think he nailed
it other comments questions on H jr5 and
again or H jr1 I'm sorry uh the intent
of this resolution was to or is to
affirm the natural right of persons and
affirm that the state and federal
government are established for the
purpose of upholding protecting and
securing these rights I'm getting it
better uh than I did I I know I asked
you to take some time to explain that
question any anything else questions go
ahead represent
jnes thank you uh just procedurally Mr
chair uh we have some new people here if
you could explain the difference as you
did for me when I first came on board a
didactic moment just explain the
difference between a resolution in HCR
and an hjr sure uh thank you represent
Jones and I know as I always like to
point out there are people watching at
home so an HR is a house resolution that
is strictly uh a product of the house if
it passes the committee or even if it
doesn't pass the committee still goes to
the house and the house votes on it and
if it passes then whatever the
resolution said I.E
resolution passed by the house for
whatever goes to whatever it's
designated to the federal delegation or
the president of United States or
whatever an HCR house concurrent
resolution involves both houses the
Senate and the house so if this were to
be an HCR would have to go from this if
it passes this body it would go to the
Senate and if it passes that body then
it would go to wherever it was meant to
be shared or directed to uh an hjr which
is what this is a house joint
resolution would go through the house if
it makes it through the house it would
go to the Senate and if it makes it
through the Senate then it also goes to
the governor so the governor has a a a
chance has a bite at this apple too to
uh support or not so hopefully that uh
clarifies those three different types of
resolutions this is an hjr hjr 1
uh other anything else on the measure
before
us uh representative gagy I saw you
first go ahead very quickly
representative Belcher your explanation
I get
it explanation what the
representative Representatives the
representative belcher's
explanation now I get it I really you
know I I I was in the weeds a little bit
but now I get it yeah the word was
esoteric that I used thank you for
taking the time for that representative
Bennett go ahead I just want to say
thank you for that clarification and I
really do think that this is a extremely
important um thing that we present and I
like the uh
careful choice of words to make sure
that we include everyone because that's
basically what our country
is so great for is our unalienable
rights thank you thank you
representative Bennett representative
Lloyd thank you um I just I think for me
um looking at this I I don't disagree at
all with the message behind it um I
think for me it's more of uh I don't
know that I'm necessarily seeing the
necessity of it at this moment in time
um so I yeah that's kind of I just want
to throw that point out there thank you
representative Lloyd representative
saber so I I feel the exact same way we
this it said it comes directly from the
Bill of Rights and I mean we already um
recognize all of that in our law um
furthermore I just have to say um the
parts that was very offputting for me
personally was the parts mening the
judeo-christian value all of that well
somewhat we agree on that I feel like
when the lines start to get blurred
between the separation of church and
state that is ultimately where democracy
Falls so I will um not be voting in
favor of this legislation thank
hands seeing
none the motion before us is OTP on hj1
the natural rights
resolution when you're ready Madame
clerk you can can call the role on that
OTP
motion Vice chairman Rollins
yes uh representative Dolan yes
representative gason yes representative
Gagney yes representative Manion yes
representative Belcher yes
representative Bennett yes
representative Hemingway yes
representative plant yes
Representative
cybert
no representative Judy is not here uh
for the clerk I vote
no representative Jones no
representative Lane no Representative
budak
no representative Harnet no
yes OTP passes vote 10
to7 representative Bel you know I'm
going to look to you for a report that
will hopefully have great clarity that
you can tell we're looking for uh
representative cyber uh I'm anticipating
a Minority Report yeah one of us will
get okay there will be a Minority Report
I'll Circle back to the ranking member
to
confirm the author of The Minority
Report okay we have three more measures
to go now these three that we're going
to finish with are three that we had
hearings on
today so I don't know that there's a
need for you all to hear me go through
the Jones act again
uh and there was some uh also some
wonderful follow on testimony on both
sides of the Jones act uh so hr10 uh I
will make the motion that was my uh HCR
that I introduced this morning and spoke
to this morning I obviously I'm going to
move OTP on
hcr1 I'll second it and I have a second
we have a second from is there an
amendment representative uh as you as
you were thank you uh repr Manion you
there is an amendment I got ahead of
myself on that um yes in fact I am going
to resend my OTP measure if uh we
haven't voted on that so I'm just going
to resend that if you'll resend your
second second uh representative Rollins
I resend my second thank you
representative Rollins yes so before we
go to uh take another motion you all
should have a copy of an amendment which
I will speak to the amendment so
proceeds usually what is happening here
is we're I am going to introduce the
amendment yes go ahead just a quick a
point of order I just want to make sure
we we accomplish this in the correct
manner am I mistaken in thinking that we
need an OTP motion on the table to
introduce the amendment yes that's what
I'm about to do okay excellent uh right
so the OTP motion on the measure itself
was rescinded and now I am making a I'm
introducing an amendment
which you all
have or should
have Mr chair
chairman sure I think the representative
was right I think you need the OTP
motion and then the amendment you have
to introduce the motion of OTP on the
amendment so procedurally we need an OTP
motion on the original
Bill and then the amendment and then I
have an I want okay I want to make sure
everybody's had a chance to look at the
assuming does anybody need
one it's the the amendment is uh just
okay uh we're going to do the same thing
we did last week with an when we had an
amendment the motion is going to be on
the amendment first if the amendment
passes then the next motion will be on
the OTP on the measure as amended if the
amendment fails then we'll go to the
original measure so I am introducing at
this time U Madam clerk the the number
of the
amendment is
H
0318 hotel as we said
in the in the military so the amendment
word and that one
word
repeal correct so rather than repeal the
Jones act in response to some feedback
that we got I got from uh both the red
team and the blue team we want to change
the word repeal to reform or
Reformation so that is the amendment uh
0318 H changed the word repeal to reform
or Reformation so that's my motion and I
I do need a second I'll second that
thank you representative rollan so we
have a motion in a second on the said
named Amendment U Madame Clerk and you
have
0318 changing the one
word so before I ask the clerk to call
the role on the amendment I will make
I'll Point make a comment on Amendment
processes when I was a a freshman
legislator I was in a different
committee and an amendment was
introduced and I noticed that uh was a
rep a representative from Bo at the time
uh who voted for the
amendment and then subsequently when we
had the the
otpa motion the same representative
voted against the otpa so being a
Freshman rookie I uh was a little bit
confused why did she vote for it and
then against it and I asked her about
that afterwards and she said and I
learned something uh she said I voted
for the amendment because it made it a
better Bill if it went forward she was
not in favor of the bill but she knew or
felt that the amendment improved the
bill I said aha okay so I I get that so
that that's the one point I want to make
to uh anyone here uh who may not like
the bill or the measure but if you think
that the amendment makes it better you
can certainly vote for the amendment and
then vote against
otpa so all that said Madam clerk when
you're ready the uh motion is on Mr
chairman go ahead yeah yeah on the
amendment can we not uh simply have a
show of hands it's been done in the past
yes uh thank you representative gagy
veteran legislator last week we did on
an amendment we did a show of hands to
save some time and I'm going to do that
again so I'm going to ask that if you're
in favor of Amendment
03188 which changes the word repeal to
all
right the clerk has 17 for zero against
the amendment so the amendment is
adopted now uh my next motion is going
to be uh
otpa uh to pass as amended we've
approved the amendment
on the
the Jones act
measure and as I just said a couple a
few minutes
ago you've already been here today
you've heard me speak at Great length on
this I'm not going to repeat everything
I just said a short time ago uh you also
heard uh other testimony both for and
against so all that said I've made the
motion and um certainly W welcome anyone
who wants to speak to any aspect of uh
the Jones act at this time
representative Manion go ahead I think
the the the word choice of changing to
reform is good because like a lot of
times we run into these situations where
they end up waving the Jones act like
left right and Center every time there's
a crisis so there's obviously some kind
of flawed with the existing system that
perhaps we should put some kind of
automatic system in there I don't know
what the resolution here would be I
support full repeal but I'm happy to
meet in the
middle thank you representative Manion
representative Belcher thank you Mr Sher
and as a actual co-sponsor of the
original legislation I I very much
appreciate and approve of the
the minor change in language I think it
improves it dramatically because I not
being a pure economic libertarian I do
appreciate certain aspects of protect
protectionism at times but the fact is
New Hampshire needs a fix we are in a
bad situation where we can't get enough
natural gas to New Hampshire because of
frankly the policies of our surrounding
neighbor States there's only so much we
can do about them but we'd like to be
able to get delivered by boat so we need
to fix thank you
representative a question a
representative Jones no relation to the
Jones act representative Jones go ahead
no relation at all sir thank you for
hearing me
um yeah I appreciate um the amendment uh
by repeal it me it sounds more like a
mandate by uh changing it to reform it's
a now it means take a look at it and fix
it
um I gave you my word that if you made
that amendment that I would vote for it
so will be voting for
thoughts representative
Lloyd thank you Mr chairman um the
amendment is great and I really
appreciate the working with us on the
amendment um unfortunately I'm probably
still going to vote against the the
measure um only because um after hearing
the test
I think that they were still saying that
as is there is still a workaround
process but I think that this amendment
should this pass makes it much better
overall thank you representative other
thoughts seeing No Hands then the motion
is
otpa ought to pass as amended on
hcr1 which invol involves pulling back
the Jones act when you're ready uh you
can call the role Madam
clerk Vice chairman Rollins
yes representative Dolan yes
representative gason yes representative
Gagney we Madame B um uh representative
Manion
yes representative beler
yes representative Bennett
yes representative Hemingway yes
representative plant yes Representative
cybert no representative Judy is
absent clerk votes uh no representative
Jones yes representative Lane
no Representative budak
no representative Harnet no and
and Mr
you otpa passes 11 to6 with one absent
thank you madam cleric 11-6
otpa on
acr10 okay we have two to go uh who's
going to do the reports I oh uh I will
do uh representative Moffett we'll do
the uh majority report represent cyber
they'll probably will there be a a
Minority Report
um we can yeah yeah I'll do something
little on that one all right we'll uh
Circle back this weekend and nail down
okay that brings us to hr12 house
resolution
12 that involves amending the Smith Mont
act we had extensive uh uh discussion
testimony earlier today that should be
fresh in everyone's mind I would think
and hope uh so I'm going to look to the
uh sponsor the prime sponsor
representative Belcher for a motion on
hr12 thank you Mr chairman I would move
on to pass motion is on to pass on hr12
looking for a second uh second
representative gagy with a second
representative Bela would you care to
speak to your motion on hr12 the Smith
Mont act if you could summ for folks
that are are watching the executive
session who didn't maybe didn't watch
the beginning of the hearing if you
could just summarize for people so they
know what we're talking about here sure
I won't believe the point but I'll offer
a quick summary which is that for most
of America's modern history there had
been a a federal law prohibiting the
propagandizing and use of uh federal
government information Warfare against
the American people that was repealed
with the 2013 smithm modernization act
in the time since then we have seen a
significant growth industry in the field
of government deciding that it wants to
be the Arbiter of Truth um in very many
ways nonpartisan ways even from
everything from covid-19 to Foreign Wars
and domestic politics it has weighed in
and it is time that we ask the federal
government to
reinstitute this prohibition on
soil and represent gagy you made the
second
ditto thank you
representative this during the earlier
discussion on this measure it came up uh
the US Aid thing uh which is very
prominently in the news this does tie
into that somewhat so it is somewhat
relevant uh we had earlier discussion on
on that uh and it was pointed out that
this measure was put in uh months ago
before the recent develop developments
of this week in terms of government
funding going
to uh medor outlets and that type of
thing other thoughts questions comments
representative uh cyber and then
representative Manion with this I just
can't get past the hypocrisy and regards
to I don't know the federal government
being always the issue when it's like
definitely corporate media Outlets
causing a huge part of the problem in
the misinformation that goes around so I
will not be supporting this
measure thank you representative
representative Manion go ahead so uh
even though it all occurred before this
modernization act we all remember like
the global war on terror and the the
weapons of mass destruction I can't even
imagine how much worse those lies would
have been should the had the federal
government put an even heavier thumb on
the scale to propagandize the United
thoughts okay seeing no other hands up
then we will move to the roll call on
the OTP motion on hr12 what to pass when
thank you uh Vice chairman Rollins
yes uh representative Dolan
yes representative gon yes
representative Gagney yes representative
Manion yes representative Belcher
yes representative Bennett
yes representative Hemingway yes
representative plant
yes Representative cybert no
no representative Judy is absent clerk
votes no representative Jones no
representative Lane no Representative
budak no representative Harnet no
Representative jurus
no and Mr Clerk or Mr chairman yes thank
you
motion passes 10 to 7 with one
absent thank you madam clerk uh H our 12
is otpd uh 10
to7 represent Belzer uh I'm going to
look to you for the committee report as
you were the prime
sponsor and uh representative seber I'll
get with you or we'll communicate on The
Minority
Report this being a Friday we have until
we'll give everybody a couple days and
then um we'll get this report and
hopefully on I'll get the information
Sunday night and get it submitted on on
Monday all right we have one more
measure it's
hcr1 it's the climate resolution it's
the one that I introduced uh earlier
this afternoon just a short time ago
as the prime sponsor I am going to make
an OTP uh motion I Mo motion ought to
pass on
hcr1 I will second that thank you rep
representative gagy seconding the OTP
motion I will speak to my motion I will
not speak much to it because uh just a
very short time ago I went on for a long
time making the case for it uh the
climate resolution the premise of it was
simply to Embrace and
encourage consideration of all
perspectives when making climate policy
uh I follow that up by giving many
examples of what I thought and the
sponsors thought were examples of some
perspectives that were getting in our
view short Sheriff uh there
were numerous uh or or a good number of
folks who testified on both sides of
that subsequently I thought the
testimony was was very good on both
sides so I'm not not going to repeat
everything that you just heard other
than uh I hope that the committee will
move this forward for the reasons that I
expressed a great length a short time
ago representative gagy you made the
second uh would you like to add anything
no it's all pretty concise I just want
everybody to get together know what
they're talking about and come to some
kind of a consensus to uh to figure this
thing out that's
all on climate change policy other
thoughts representative cyber when part
of the bill calls oneide being an
alarmist I was like perfectly fine when
the guys came in here and were willing
to seemingly come together but that's
not something I ever see within the
state house when it comes to either side
um and so it also doesn't seem when
we're passing a piece of legislation
that uses the term and accuses one side
of being alarmist that that's not just
completely one-sided in of itself
also I am going to vote against this
because I come here every day and I get
elected for the reasons of coming here
to be objective for two sides or
whatever side you know looking at for
all different standpoints and how it can
do damage and that's what I come here
already prepared to do and I'm sorry
that there's people in this room that
don't do that
already thank you
representative uh go ahead
representative Dolan thank you uh
Mr chair uh I just wanted to uh say that
in my other life I live on the municipal
and County government committee and want
to alert the committee members that
HB 453 is under consideration at this
time and that along this same line of
thought will be a discussion of
restricting the use of snow and ice REM
removal equipment to be used by
Municipal uh governments and also
individuals in their in their homes that
they will no longer be able to uh use
gasoline combustion Motors in order to
remove snow and ice and what would have
to revert to some type of an electrical
device uh and the and the thought of uh
of what that would do if if I'm thinking
Municipal the recapitalization of very
expensive equipment for for towns that
are already trying to control operating
costs uh so it's something to to to
understand that that that's in and about
our process and our uh potential
legislation thank you for sharing that
representative Dolan so your your point
is that the the equipment issue purchase
issue is being driven somewhat by uh one
one side of the of the climate
right issue is that and they're going to
be real impacts uh financially both to
homeowners and to uh Community uh
government thank
you uh go go ahead representative
C I was just gonna say like it's not
gonna pass that committee
sorry but but it's not going to pass
that committee I mean let's be honest
just because somebody entered a bill
they it's still due due diligence so I
think that's a little point is mute here
well I M if I may of gagy has his hand
ahead uh representative cyber you you
mentioned due diligence this is what
this bill would do due diligence get all
sides together put them in a room you
have to I was a kickboxer you put
somebody in a room and you settle
something you settle one way or the
other and and whoever whoever has the
better argument who has the better facts
will win out and if the the the climate
change Advocates say that we'll because
of us we're we're losing this planet
then if it's
irrefutable uh
facts I'm going to be on board but until
that happens I want everybody to get
together and figure it
out rep uh just a quick response to that
and then representative Lloyd the the
intent of the measure which was my
measure was to embrace and encourage
discussion uh I know that some of the
examples uh that I gave were certainly
uh somewhat pointed but I think just
during the subsequent testimony I could
go on and on I think everyone who
testified uh I learned from everyone who
testified the the gentleman from Germany
uh I thought was he was neutral on the
measure but he I think uh provided some
lessons that I I learned from and I
think I hope that here and watching at
home learn from so to your point that
goes largely to some of the intent of
the measure was to get a broad
discussion that some of us feel is has
been lacking because of concerns that
some perspectives have have been U
questioned I made the case for that
earlier uh representive Lloyd go ahead
you had your hand up thank you um and I
just wanted to speak on I understand the
intent of this of this measure and I
absolutely agree with it um however I
can't vote for it
because I just don't know that it's
necessary um given
that Avenues are out there that present
both sides um whether it be a conference
or um research uh done by scientists
online or um or anything like that and I
think that on when it comes to
legislation for us I I also agree with
um the piece of testimony that we
received that said as legislators it is
our due diligence to look at everything
and that I mean I I usually come here
wholeheartedly and I do appreciate the
folks who have been here because they
have been willing to hear testimony and
have learned a lot as as time goes on um
but I just I don't know that this
measure is necessarily the way forward
with it thank you representative uh
representative Lane uh please
um I just I feel like I'm I don't want
to repeat too much but like others I
really learned a lot from the testimony
and and I also um come every time and
listen I do listen and I do try to
listen and I represent both both teams
from my uh from my district and try and
think about what is best for all of them
when I make a decision I think my
problem with this um piece of
legislation is that it uses inflammatory
language and it's um pointing fingers
and I think if you truly want to build
you know a something where we can all
sit down and talk together and listen we
need to avoid some of the inflammatory
and finger pointing and I think that
there are both people on both teams that
do that so I
I could go for like the the the the
sample that he gave out I I would vote
for that um I just it's just
inflammatory thank you representative
Lane and as I earlier uh acknowledged I
I think I use the term pointed some of
the whereas points uh did reflect some
passion and I think that the passion was
prompted by like with any resolution uh
any resolution is prompted by some
emotion or some position or feeling that
something needs to be said uh that's the
definition of a resolution and uh I
understand that the language was
probably somewhat pointed uh as I said
and I get that but I again would point
out that uh I think an effective
resolution maybe could have been worded
differently we can all argue about that
or discuss that but I don't want to
Discount the passion behind any
resolution that uh that comes forward
whether to this committee or any other
committee other hands representative uh
uh representative Belcher and then
representative
Dolan thank you Mr chairman I will uh be
supporting this resolution because of
what I believe my own personal beliefs
on the issue and my personal beliefs on
the issue include the following the
origin of the scare of extreme
catastrophic anthropomorphic climate
change in America originated in this
country decades and decades ago as a
Soviet active measure meant to get us to
our own economy when then the
most obvious solution in the world
presented itself in the form of nuclear
energy clean nuclear energy it was also
go figure subject to Soviet active
measures against it which is one of the
reasons that you'll find even to this
day many of the major names against
or rather the alarmists the ones who are
claiming catastrophic climate change are
also remain against nuclear
energy so my foremost concern on the
matter is very simple we live in a cold
climate we need energy so my
constituents don't freeze to death in
the dark while starving they need energy
we need it for our standard of life and
we have so tainted the conver ation over
years and years of bad science that's
been driven along the lines of well it's
simple you don't get funded in the
industry that is primarily government
funded unless you're going to pursue a
certain line of thought anything to the
contrary tends to not get funded and
that's that's well documented at this
point in fact it ties in with the other
stuff we've just been talking about us
Aid and all this other stuff so yeah we
need to take a look at the whole broad
issue and see what is really going on
and we need to stop passing so many
economically harmful policies that are
driving up our electricity rates that at
this rate threaten to destabilize our
Northeast grid you may or may not know
this but there was at least two
emergencies declared on our grid over
the past year on days where we almost
didn't have enough electricity to make
it through almost had to have brownouts
that's where we're at because we're
demonizing the obvious the obvious
answer which is nuclear energy thank you
thank you represent Bel representative
Dolan go ahead yes thank you Mr chair
just to follow up uh the legislation
that I mentioned about uh snow removal
equipment the comment was that there's
no way the committee would pass that I
can tell you that this week in executive
session the committee vote was N9 to9
tie and it was voted to retain it so for
further
considerations thank you for verifying
that represent Don so the committee that
this measure you described came to had a
nine to9 vote on it right okay thank you
for that anything
else uh I see two hands representative
Bennett and then representative Manion
go ahead representative Bennett uh since
I'm kind of new uh thank you for letting
me speak um I don't know like all the
like stuff that happens underneath or
you know like you're mentioning there's
some kind of tension or whatever ever um
I think just based on what we heard
today the ones who were talking about um
the gentleman that had the new furnace
and got a money from the government for
a new car to have the green
energy and though the people that were
discussing that type of
situation said they didn't agree with
this because they didn't want to talk
about it because the facts are the fact
so I think that just that alone tells me
that we need this because we need to
make sure that
people understand
that um you know there are two sides we
heard two sides of the story and we all
deserve the respect that we have our
side of the story in my opinion if we
our schools just got solar panels and
I'm wondering ing you know over time if
we had bought new furnaces and paid for
oil and paid for electricity like
normal at once those solar panels are
done have we really saved money we
aren't going to know for the next 20 to
30 years we're just guessing so I think
all of these things need to be brought
out in the open I think this just by
what was demonstrated today that we do
need
this thank you for that representative
Bennett representative Manion so I kept
asking questions that were specifically
about climate anxiety and children um
there's you know that we have like an up
an upand cominging um generation of
children that are like much more anxious
than previous generations and some
attribute it to social media but I think
it's all kind of like one thing together
and uh there was one of the experts was
mentioning that like oh well they should
be afraid it's like of what like this
the world going to end in 10 years and
it's like well it's not going to end in
10 years like then why are we making
these children terrified over a hyp
phical sure and that is what you just
said is what we've already gone over uh
we've heard before and thank you for
reiterating that anything else uh go
ahead The Honorable representative from
gtown thank you Mr chair one of the
other reasons that I want this thing to
be on the table and recognized is
because you know we've heard reference
to um government subsidies to all of the
energy Industries to the fossil fuel
industry the green energy industry and
anytime you hear government subsidies I
want you to take a step back and think
taxpayer money that is taken under the
threat of violence if you don't comply
like that is somebody's money that was
taken by the government that is now
being distributed to manipulate the
market in some way and if you can't have
an honest conversation about every side
of this issue then you can't have an
honest conversation about how the tax
dollars are being redistributed to
influence the
market thank you for that representative
representative Rollins thank you Mr
chair um earlier Mr Gage talked and I
asked him the question what he what he
how he Heats his how and and what he
uses for a vehicle he's been in before I
knew what his answers are going to be
he's updated he's got an EV car now
that's great but the his answer to the
oil was this is all he can afford now I
understand that completely that that's
all he can afford but there's a lot of
people less fortunate than what he is
and how are they going to afford these
new ways going with the green energy if
we don't find the solutions and work
together
first thank you
representative representative
Jones Thank you Mr chair um I was truly
intrigued when I saw the the title of
this resolution I thought maybe it was
something I can work with but when I saw
the text and it seemed to be very
accusatory uh I thought it should be a
little more impartial and uh a more
impartial document that we could send to
the full house so I'll be opposing
this thank you
representative other
hands saying no other hands uh when
you're ready Madam chair I know that
there are people watching at home there
are people watching at the state house
hoping that we finish by
4:30 because uh I want to thank uh the O
staff who who stay around until we're
done and it looks like we're almost done
so those that are watching watching uh
this is our last vote on our last
measure when when you're ready Madam
Madam
yes representative Dolan yes
representative gas yes representative
Gagney yes representative Manion yes
representative Belcher yes
representative Bennett yes
representative Hemingway yes representa
cybert
no representative Judy is absent clerk
votes no representative uh Jones
no representative Lane no Representative
bataki no Representative
hernet no Representative jurus
yes motion passes 10 to 7 with one
absent
yeah thank you madam clerk I want to
thank uh the subs who came in today I
want to thank the members of the
committee we've now completed hearings
and exec sessions on all 16 me measures
assigned to us uh the ranking member and
I will work on the reports we we will
need to identify some speakers uh at the
uh upcoming uh sessions uh and also pis
but other than that uh We've uh pretty
much finished our work thank you again
uh we'll see what happens with crossover
we typically get a couple of Senate
measures so uh safe travels and and
thank you again all right who's doing
the report I'll uh I will do the report
and I'll get with representative sabert
on um The Minority Report oh yeah yeah
we're working it out now I'll be
excellent okay we'll be in touch thanks
again